Cha-cha-cha-cha, cha-cha-cha...
Hello everybody!
Welcome back to Oblivion...
Cha, cha, cha, cha, howdy doody.
Hello.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
If I sound a little different, it's because... Oh, wait, I just pressed something weird.
Wait, no.
It's because I got a new mic.
So I might sound a little different.
And if it sounds like a... Like a... Like a... If it sounds like a peak sometimes or something... That might be... That might be why.
I'm still messing with the settings, so... Yes.
But... Check, check, check.
Mic, check.
One, two.
Mintus, sexitus.
No.
Pretty good mic.
I'd say so.
It cost me enough that it should be pretty good.
What kind of mic?
It's my first ever big girl mic.
I got it so that... Oh my god.
I can't hear myself talk.
I got it.
Because I have lots of things to record.
And I wanted it to be... I don't have time to go to a studio.
So I was like, well, if I get a big girl mic... Then I can just record at home and it will sound good.
I don't know about studio quality.
But... It's a nice mic.
I looked up what mic Taylor Swift uses.
Her mic is...
$10,000.
I did not buy that.
Good news.
My Minto mug has shipped.
Yippee!
I saw... I saw one person post theirs on Twitter, so...
Mint is a Swifty.
No!
I, uh... Googled... I don't remember what I Googled, but you know how sometimes it will say, like, uh... It will give you, like, a little... A little... Not the AI.
Not the AI overview, but it will give you the drop-down of, like, I guess, frequently asked questions.
And one of them was, what mic does Taylor Swift use?
And I was like, oh, I'm kind of curious.
And I didn't even see the name of it.
I just saw the price.
My eyes turned into money, money signs, and I was like, wow!
Um...
My mug and pushpins arrived a couple days ago.
Thank you for getting them!
But my mic...
Uh...
Is the Newman...
TLM-103.
And you might also gasp at the price, because it's, uh...
Yeah.
But I was like, I want that studio quality, baby!
So...
Maybe it sounds sturdy or quality.
New man.
New man!
I suppose I can contribute to the peasant ghost's mic fun.
Since she did rid our fair city of that bothersome wood elf.
No, today we're gonna go...
We're gonna go murder some people.
Wishing a happy May Day.
Thank you!
A Minto streamed during mental breakdown.
Oh!
Um...
Be okay.
Down!
Thank you so much for the 20th!
Thank you!
Yeah!
Today we murder!
Today...
I murder!
I'm for self murder!
Do you think if they made a million dollar, Mike Taylor Swift would use it?
Probably!
Probably, huh?
Yeah, today we're gonna murder...
Murder...
And...
Um...
Mordor...
And...
I don't know!
I guess we'll get my horse back!
I missed the plush in the mug!
Oh!
The mug was restocked!
So...
Um...
Calamity...
If you missed it...
And you...
I probably should've posted it on YouTube...
My bad...
I only posted the restock on...
Twitter...
But it...
Oh!
It sold out again!
I did not know...
Oh my gosh!
But it was a...
It was a small quantity...
Of restock!
Like, it wasn't...
Crazy!
So...
Thank you so much!
Holy moly!
Oh my gosh!
Kanye East!
Thank you for the...
Thank you so much for the...
I'll become a channel member as soon...
As well as soon...
Once I figure out how to...
LOL iOS problems...
Is that a problem on there?
Also...
ClArthur's gonna defeat the gang stalker...
What is that?
Skin grad...
Hiya Mito!
It's mine and Kermit's birthday today!
Could I get a happy birthday?
Happy birthday!
Enter name here!
And also...
Kermit!
Wait, like...
Kermit the frog?
No way...
No way it's that guy's birthday...
Don't do it on mobile...
It costs more...
For membership?
It does?
No way!
Seriously?
It costs more?
iOS tax...
Oh!
I try to keep my memberships low anyway...
Cause I'm like...
I know probably so many people wanna have memberships for...
For other...
Uh... VTubers...
I don't do so many...
Membership streams anyway...
I don't really have much to post...
So...
I was like...
I'll try and keep it cheap...
So that...
Um...
You can feel like...
You're not spending so much on it...
Uh...
Thank you so much for the...
Thank you!
Effect yourself!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for the...
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for the...
Squid!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
It's a bargain!
Why?
Well, like I said...
You get the emotes...
I don't...
I...
I did a membership stream yesterday...
Uh...
I...
Yeah...
I do...
I'm kind of whenever...
Thank you!
Thank you for the gift of...
I feel like you could charge more...
No!
It's okay!
Like I said...
I...
I am so comfortable...
I don't need to charge more...
I think it would be...
Way too much...
Probably...
Hmm...
But yeah...
Well...
Oh gosh!
No!
This is not the...
Send us...
Not the gifting membership time!
Well...
Thank you so much for the...
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
What about a higher tier that does nothing?
No!
Did you see the new look...
Look up...
Shiroko and Hoshino figures...
Oh yes!
I did!
But yeah...
Sadly...
No Koharu...
My girl is always shafted...
Happy May Day!
Wee!
Alfredo!
Thank you so much for the...
Tag gifted Deku!
Gotta super to balance out the cheap memberships...
No...
Guys, I'll be honest...
Today I had kind of a poopy day...
So I'm feeling a little...
Feeling a little...
So I'm gonna take out my anger...
On these three guys...
I'm gonna murder them...
But hopefully it was a good day for you...
Maybe after this...
I'll get some pizza...
Fra...
It's Friday...
Friday pizza...
Friday pizza time...
Okay...
Been so long...
No regrets!
Thank you!
T-G-I-F, baby!
T-G-I-F!
I just ate some pizza!
Let's go!
Thanks for being you!
Thanks...
Me...
For being me!
So let's get into the game...
Last time...
I got arrested...
And...
Today we're going to...
Skingrad...
And we're gonna...
We were gonna...
We...
Okay, last time...
We saw what happened...
If you...
Snitch on...
Glarthor...
But this time...
I think I kinda wanna indulge him...
And murder all the people...
Have you seen that I'm yours to command, sir knight?
I have...
I don't think I have...
Could you take out...
My anger too?
I got so tired at the gym earlier...
That I saw the mirror...
I have dark bags into my eyes...
Like I've been in a fight...
Oh gosh...
If you're at the gym...
You should...
Go to one of the punching bags...
And punch it...
And pretend that it's a real person...
Show your...
Show me your kittens...
Thank you for the...
Thank you...
Alright...
Let's try this...
Sure you want to load this game?
Yes...
So we're not gonna rat him out...
We're gonna...
See...
But I need this guy to leave...
Cause...
Uh...
So basically...
Basically...
Oh...
This is E-Tina...
Definitely not E-T in a wig...
As an Italian trained chef...
And recently ranked head chef...
Let me make you that pizza...
Whoa...
Oh...
Mamma mia...
Real-a pizza...
I'm sorry...
But hey...
We have an American Pope now...
So...
I can say that...
Mamma mia...
Real-a pizza...
Mhahaha...
Deep dish...
I don't think that's true...
Mhahaha...
Maybe...
Um...
So we got this...
Cool little note from Glarthur...
And it says...
List of death...
That these people must be killed...
Which is...
Bernadette...
Penelis...
Tudius...
Sextius...
And...
David...
Cerulier...
I don't actually know where that guy is...
It says kill him first...
Where do I find him?
I actually don't know where he is...
I'm guessing by the...
Look at...
There's Glarthur over there...
I wish I could...
Emote at him...
Hahahaha...
Uh...
It's 1am...
In his home...
Probably...
Yeah...
But like...
Where is it?
Slash dance...
I could go into the other places...
What if I killed all three of them?
In this...
Like...
In the span of tonight...
So...
Sneakily...
Nobody cares that I'm wandering around...
At night...
I'm such a mis...
I'm a mysterious creature of the night...
I think...
Sextius is...
Actually...
This city is so...
I don't know where anything is actually...
I have to go outside for the vineyard...
All the city are pretty mazy...
Are they?
Oh, this is Sextius' house!
I do remember...
Yes, see, see...
I knew, I knew...
Well...
Tutius Sextius...
Alright...
What a name...
I know...
Wow...
It's a beautiful night...
Um...
I went on the wrong side...
That's okay...
I think it's the other side...
Is the vineyard...
The west gate...
Skingrad...
This place is cursed...
You got Tutius Sextius...
Uh...
If you...
It's called Skingrad...
You got Glarthur...
Greetings!
I think this city...
Just needs to...
It...
It can...
Doesn't need...
It...
Can...
Wait, am I going the right way?
Look at this!
There's a little...
There's a...
Training...
Archery...
Needs to burn?
Yeah...
Hello from Akiva!
I went to Deer Stage...
But they were fully booked up...
I told...
Them about...
Wait...
I told them a VTuber recommended it...
And they asked if it was you...
There were some other Wisps...
And they let me join their table...
Everyone there is so nice!
Wait, I think I saw your pictures...
You guys are so cute...
Also...
I saw...
I saw comments about...
I tried to fix some of the graphics of the game...
So hopefully...
It looks fine on my end...
But if it looks a little wonky...
On your guys' end...
Just let me know, okay?
I'll try and fix some more...
But yeah...
I think I saw your pictures...
And you guys saw my Oshi ID...
She's so stinking cute...
Wait...
I'm back at the church...
Oh shoot...
I went in a big old circle...
Looks fine?
Looks good?
Oh, good, good...
I tried...
I tried taking...
I saw comments...
And I was like...
I will follow...
The recommendations...
So thank you...
All who gave...
The recommendations...
Wait...
I'm...
Oh, this is the West Gate...
Ugh...
Here we go...
Okay...
Let's go kill David...
David...
Do you think he's...
Oh...
Sorry, my...
My computer just acted weird...
David...
If I were David...
Where would my house be?
He's not in the stables...
He's in the vineyard...
But where is his house?
Oh gosh...
My computer's acting really weird...
Okay, hold on...
Give me a second...
I don't know why I was fine last time...
Let's do this...
Okay...
Should be fine though...
They're at the red markers?
No...
I don't think so...
Oh wait...
Maybe...
Wait...
Whose house is that?
Can we be for sure?
The house was in town...
You saw it before...
I did?
Hello...
Oh wait...
Okay...
So we have three houses...
Oh...
I see...
Okay...
So this must lead to...
David...
Probably...
Greetings...
Is it here?
Yes...
Oh, they're brothers...
Okay...
Do you think anybody will notice...
If I...
Oh wait...
It's a hard one...
Okay...
Talk Mr. M...
Thank you for the five guests...
Thank you...
Okay...
I remember how to do this...
Oh...
Like so?
You should probably save first...
Oh, it's okay...
We still have a...
We're right by next to the church...
I think...
So...
I have my other save...
It's like a rhythm game...
Oh...
Whoa...
Okay...
After...
After last time...
I was like...
I will not be bested by these locks again...
Oh...
First try, baby...
First try...
Hey...
Okay...
I got my fists...
Wait...
Let's get my...
Uh...
My bow and arrow...
Ooh...
They should be asleep...
No?
Your honor...
She's cracked...
If I were a brother...
I'd be upstairs...
Sleeping...
Oh...
That's the basement...
Don't care...
Let's go upstairs...
I'm scared...
Yeah, I heard the root...
I heard it...
Wait...
What?
Hm...
Wait, what?
Wait...
Where did I...
Huh?
Wait...
No...
Heard somebody...
It was...
This...
Oh my gosh...
Wait...
Do you think that guy will notice?
Do you think that guy will care?
Wait...
Where's their...
Where...
Their house is...
What?
Oh, is it...
I literally...
Did not read...
Are they in the basement?
First try...
Stairs to the left?
Oh...
Wait...
Hold on...
Okay...
Stairs to the left?
I'm blind...
No...
I'm so blind...
Oh...
Alright...
I'm sneaking...
I hear the root...
My sneak has increased...
Equip arrows?
Wait...
What do you mean?
Doesn't it...
Doesn't it do that by itself?
Oh no...
Steel arrow...
There we go...
Thank you...
Okay...
Hold on...
I'm gonna make a hard save...
Save game...
Wait...
What time is it anyway?
Let's...
Save game...
New save...
Who are you?
I found him!
I can pick his pockets...
He got 10 gold...
I'm gonna take his house key...
What do you think you're doing?
Oh my god...
How are you alive?
Or...
How are you awake?
By the Nine Divines...
Assault!
I have killed David...
Davide...
As Glarthur requested...
Oh...
When I have killed everyone on Glarthur's list...
I should meet him at midnight...
Behind the great chapel for my payment...
Let's go...
And take the route...
How did he feel his pockets getting stolen from?
Um...
I'm leaving...
So nobody knows I was ever here...
Or I could...
Let's see...
What else is in here?
Oh!
This is a door to Skingrod...
I'm stupid...
Oh my god...
How cute!
They got a little balcony...
Aww...
Two sisters...
Lodge!
I just killed a brother...
I just killed one brother...
Wait a second...
I got the key!
Did I not?
Why do I have to...
Why do I have to use this?
Two sisters...
One brother...
Somebody sees me...
Wait, who?
Oh, you're right...
Whomst?
Who is seeing me?
Oh, wait...
Where?
How?
Not anymore...
That's weird...
He didn't get it...
Because he woke up...
Seriously?
Wait...
I'm so good at this now...
I'm too good at this scam...
Wait, who sees me?
Oh my god...
Stop right there...
Nobody breaks the law on my watch...
Oh...
I'm confiscating your stolen goods...
Now pay your fine...
Or it's off to jail...
Um...
Maybe I should reload...
Then pay with your blood!
Load game...
This one...
Yes...
Was it because...
Did he hear him?
So I have to kill him first...
I have to kill him in his sleep...
By the Nine Divines...
Assault!
He's fine...
Who opened the door?
Oh...
Um...
Wait...
I...
I don't know what to do...
I think I should kill him...
By the Nine Divines...
Assault!
Stop!
What?!
You violated the law!
Pay the court a fine...
Or serve your sentence!
Your stolen goods are now...
Forfeit!
No!
Where did you come from?
Oh...
That was a sting operation...
He's like peeking through the door!
Oh...
How much is the fine?
80 gold, that's it!
I think we have that...
Well, obviously we have that...
Because I can...
Um...
What if I...
That's too bad!
I was hoping you'd resist arrest...
Here's Johnny!
Okay...
Here's the procedure...
We go to the castle...
First, we search you...
Confiscate any stolen goods...
I didn't take anything!
Then you pay your fine...
And we release you...
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait!
No!
Um...
Wait a second...
My game...
I'm reloading...
The Nirn rule...
I didn't take that!
Let's see...
How can I kill him...
In one...
Swoop!
I think the...
Sword would be better...
Maybe with the dagger...
Can I use the blade of woe?
The blade of woe!
Daggers do more stealth damage if you have one...
Is that...
Is this a dagger?
Oh, it looks like a dagger...
Blade of woe!
Let's try it...
She's too good...
Okay, this is my first time stabbing a person...
Shut up!
I stole...
Okay, here I go...
No!
Assault!
Am I supposed to be impressed?
Uh...
That didn't work...
Okay, hold on...
We're gonna get this!
We're gonna...
Do I have to shut the door?
Will that make it so that...
They don't...
Don't...
Use a power attack?
What's that?
Wait, what's a power attack?
Use a gun!
Okay...
Shut up!
Hold the attack button down...
Okay...
Alright, we're just...
Chillin' in this guy's room...
Oh, wait...
No, no, no...
Uh...
You...
Blade of Woe...
Blade of Keanu Reeves...
Whoa...
Alright...
Hold the click...
Oh...
I think somebody...
No, no...
Die you...
Wait...
How are you still alive?
Oh...
Whoa!
I think he just died...
A little bit of privacy?
Is that what you wanted?
Oh...
By the nine divines!
Assault!
Oh my god!
He knows magic!
Ah...
Oh...
He decided to peek out from under the bed...
Now run...
Run...
Ah...
There's no way I can do this!
Guys, I think I need to come back to this...
I think I need to come back to this quest once I'm stronger...
Maybe...
Maybe once I can...
Once I...
Am...
Uh...
Hmm...
Once I can...
One shot him...
You know?
You are only level two?
Yeah...
I'm only level two...
Uh...
Yeah...
Then pay with your blood!
Oh, I think he poisoned me...
You elves are all the same!
Oh, shoot!
All flash and no fury!
I'm...
Oh gosh, this guy is tough!
Okay...
Let's load the game...
I'm gonna leave...
We're gonna leave the brother's house...
Can you headshot?
I tried!
I did try!
I don't think it...
I don't think it did much...
Okay...
Let's leave...
See you later...
I will be back...
But...
I am going to...
Ransack your...
Other...
Oh...
This is a door to outside...
I'm so stupid...
Oh no...
Wait...
Nobody see me?
I'm an idiot...
I thought it was a place to loot...
Oh shoot...
In my...
Just jump down...
They'll see me...
I think...
No?
Wait a second...
I can loot these though...
Nothing...
Any money?
You're a success...
Oh...
Repair Hammer...
You're a successful...
Vineyard...
No...
You should have so much money...
Oh...
Gold...
I see...
Two gold...
Rob them...
Of all they're worth...
Okay...
So not that door...
Obviously...
Reinforced door...
Where does it go to?
Okay...
Alright...
You got...
An urd?
Who's in that?
It's like I wasn't even here...
Let's go steal from their basement...
If you have poison in inventory...
You could apply it to the arrow...
Yeah...
I saw some people saying that I should...
Try a poison arrow...
I do want to...
I...
Am curious...
Will the people...
Oh my gosh...
It's actual wine...
I know there's level scaling in this game...
Do the people also scale with the levels...
Or is it just like the...
The big baddies...
Okay...
They have a whole lot of nothing...
Wait...
What's this?
Upper...
House...
Upper wall hangings...
This entitles the bearer...
To various wall hangings...
That will promptly...
That will be promptly...
Delivered to your home...
In Skingrad...
Six tapestries...
Five paintings...
Oh...
Okay...
It's so...
It's worth so much...
Happy May Day...
It's also my birthday today...
Happy birthday...
Shadow of yore...
Yay...
Alright...
Let's leave...
What is that green?
Steal it?
Wait...
I already went in here...
What?
I have to unlock...
I have to do it again?
No!
I've already done this!
I'm too good...
I didn't realize that if I stole it...
Okay...
Wait...
So...
Take...
I've really improved with my lockpicking, huh?
Oh...
And nobody saw...
Hi Gunther...
I tried...
I really did...
Can I break into...
Glarthur...
Sorry...
Your name's not Gunther...
Where's your house?
I'd like to break into there...
What time is it?
Oh no...
It's almost 6am...
So people are gonna start waking up...
Okay...
I'm not talking to you...
Short...
Shorty...
Get out of my face...
Okay...
We should...
Nothing...
I'm almost...
Wondering...
I wonder if I get more money...
By...
Killing Glarthur...
Or if I get more money...
By killing the three people...
Um...
Why not both?
You can cash in both?
No way...
Seriously?
I do wanna see...
You can grab 800...
800 dollars...
800 from his home...
If you turn him in...
How much do I get...
If I...
Greetings to you...
Greetings...
Well...
How much do I get...
If I kill the people?
Isn't it a thousand or something?
800 bucks...
Let's see...
Okay...
Um...
I want to go...
Find my horse...
So I think we'll do that for now...
What is it now?
Uh...
But it was...
Oh golly...
1000 if you kill them...
Kill first, get paid...
Then take the 800...
I think that's what we'll do...
Huh?
We'll blame it all on him...
Wouldn't that be the best option?
We...
Got locked up at...
Kvatch...
So let's journey that way...
I get you're trying to sneak around...
But the guards keep getting alerted...
Oh, I'm on the wrong...
The wrong way...
Yeah...
We can just blame him...
It's the perfect crime...
I just have to get stronger...
Hello lady...
Lady who's doing necromancy...
She's kind of a freak...
Have pity...
Beautiful lady...
What?
Did he just...
Call me a beautiful lady?
Uh...
Okay...
Um...
Hail...
Oh, he said hail...
Have a pity...
Beautiful lady...
Poor sucker doesn't know I'm E.T.
in a wig...
Alright, let's go get my horse back...
We gotta go to...
Kvatch...
I'm on the right path, right?
Yes...
Just follow the path...
And we might see...
Some fun things along the way...
We're just gonna run there...
I know...
I can fast travel...
But I like running...
I like seeing all the sights...
And all the...
Sorry, I'm lagging...
Even...
Why was I not lagging last time...
And I'm lagging this time?
Is that guy a friend or...
Oh...
Absolutely not...
Hmm...
I think maybe I was...
Because of the settings I changed...
Maybe that's why I'm lagging...
I'll take that...
And I'll take my arrow back...
I guess I will...
Wait a second...
No, nevermind...
Dagger is nothing...
Cursed mine...
We could level up in here...
Probably...
Nice shootin'...
Rootin' tootin'...
You can level now...
Oh, that's right!
I can level up because of the...
Thing in the corner...
Maybe we can sleep in here...
Abandon...
Steal arrow...
Oh, that's mine...
I'm so stupid...
How do you do...
I'm hearing...
Someone's talking...
She's just...
They're like...
Oh, they're in there...
Oh!
You got this...
Stupid...
Stupid doesn't know how to open the door...
Just push it!
I was trying to listen to their conversation...
What?
Was I not sneaky enough?
Can I get you through the door?
Dang...
That's a shame...
Uh...
I don't wanna open it...
But...
Um...
Let me try here...
Perfect!
Oh, shoot...
Oh...
You're good...
You got this...
What the...
My aim is terrible...
Take my arrows back...
Thread the needle...
Swing my sword...
Let's try it...
Jump on my sword while you can...
Wait...
Is this...
Is that on her?
Or is that the door?
Uh-oh, wait...
I don't know...
Actually...
Wait...
That's the door!
No?
Try in first person...
Oh, true, right?
I don't know if it'll make a difference...
Let's try...
Hmm...
I'm leaving...
Is that ET?
Who's at...
Depends who's asking...
How does shooting through the gap even work?
Oh, there's a dog here!
Oh my god...
I hope to be your friend...
If only Glarther thought bandits were stalking him...
I know, right?
I also found Ayami's new book...
Yes!
You know what's so funny?
I still haven't even seen that book...
So...
We'll come back...
And let's go sleep somewhere...
So that I can level up...
Pet the good boy...
I think he was after me...
I don't think he was a good boy...
Okay...
It's loading...
And so...
I too...
Am loading...
I will be a little...
You need a hand, buddy...
I think I go this way...
Yes...
Three frame minto...
What's that over there?
It's glowing...
Oh my gosh!
Ouch!
Oh my god!
I'm getting ambushed?
Right now?
Uh...
Uh-oh...
Wait, this is bad...
This is bad, bad...
How did I miss?
Wait!
How am I missing?
This is...
What?
There we go...
Ouchah!
Third person's whack?
Okay...
Maybe...
Oh my gosh...
Okay...
Maybe I start fighting in...
In...
What the?
This is better than mine?
Maybe I start fighting in...
First person...
I didn't realize that a person was over... Oh, Steel.
No.
They came out and they came after me!
You sons of bitches.
Yeah, Steel is better.
Where'd that other guy go that I killed?
I think he's over here.
Sorry, I just like the third person so much.
But for combat, I can switch.
Is that him?
No, that's a rock.
Oh my gosh, I'm five frames per second.
It's fine, as long as the game looks good.
Is the game lagging for you guys?
I don't mind if I lag as long as the game looks good.
The game looks good?
Okay.
Don't mind me then, it's fine.
It's just...
Being a VTuber is hefty hefty.
Where is he?
I don't know where I killed him.
I killed a man and I can't even remember where.
Oh well.
It was...
Oh, wait, there he is.
He was here the whole time.
Should I take the dagger?
I feel like I could probably buy a better one.
Hefty hefty hefty.
Buy a better one?
Yeah.
Hefty hefty hefty.
What's this?
Oh.
You draw power from the well.
Okay, I could have used that, maybe.
Five seconds ago.
That's not a friend either, probably.
Why is everybody hate...
Why is everybody camp and hate me?
Stop running.
I can't aim with you, doing that.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, you're a wizard.
You're a wizard bandit.
Oh, shoot.
That's right.
Oh!
Oh my god, he seems so close though.
You're scaring me!
Did you just parry that?
Take them all.
Ugh.
You all right, Etina?
Everybody's out to get you all the time.
Fat Ramp Camp.
I could sleep here.
Let's try it.
We'll sleep for one hour.
Honk shu.
And we've reached level three!
Okay.
Let's see.
What's the stuff that's good for...
A...
Stealth again.
More agility.
Oh, I can do plus five.
Agility will help with bow and dagger damage.
Perfect.
Okay, yeah.
Agility, agility.
Agility.
I'll even do some more speed.
What's willpower do again?
I wish I could read it.
Oh, show details.
Magicka.
We don't need that.
Maximum health?
That might be good too.
Wait, I can't do any more?
I can only pick three things.
Okay.
Oh, this also is a maximum.
So maybe we'll do the endurance instead.
Well, if I can only...
Oh, okay.
That might be good.
Strength lets you carry more loot.
More loot is good.
No.
Strength is better earlier IMO.
Drop speed.
Wait, so maybe we do strength.
Oops.
And endurance?
Like so.
Let's try that instead.
That'll give us a lot more HP too.
Okay.
Back to lag.
Thank you, guys.
Let's continue onwards.
We're just...
I don't even know what the...
Well gave me.
Wow, what a pretty path.
Wait, I see the...
I see the kingdom all the way from here.
I see some...
Oh, those are not birds.
I was gonna say, I see some birds.
Oh, they're guarding a cave.
See that?
Wait.
Is this like a village or something?
Or...
Is there a...
House there?
Is this like an imp village?
Ultimate snipe?
I should've...
Oh God.
Oh wait.
He's coming.
Wait, he's taking the pathway?
He's so kind.
He's taking the path.
Hit!
Oh God.
Just...
I got him.
Give me my arrows back.
For now, I want to take back all my steel arrows.
Look at his tiny little butt.
He looks like an action figure.
That other guy didn't even notice.
Wait, what does...
What are these houses then?
I don't know what happened to my other arrow.
So sad.
He looks like a little action figure.
Fire light cave.
Okay.
Before we...
Alright.
But, but, but.
Just like that guys, but.
We're going...
This way.
We're following the path.
This game has so many things to distract you.
I know!
I don't...
I...
It's not like I dislike the...
Thought Chibi would have freed up enough resources to not need FSR frame gen.
If it's too choppy for you, it's fine to turn it back on.
Oh, the game is fine for me.
It's really a matter of if you guys are bothered by the Chibi or not.
Um...
You know the character...
Your character looks like a Dark Crystal Gelfling.
Like...
That movie, Dark Crystal.
Not at all?
Okay, that's fine.
Oh.
Oh, I think I killed him.
What's that?
Oh.
Who's there?
Where?
Somebody that...
I killed him, but somebody else is here.
What's that?
Nothing.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, shoot.
Sorry, I killed your friend.
How much you got?
He's got...
Laced...
I'm sorry, what do these look like on you?
The laced...
Oh.
They're not lacy at all.
Wait.
I like the...
The cheetah pattern.
I'm a big fan.
What do you got?
Lockpick.
I'll take that.
Weak poison.
So, I got to figure out how to make...
Um...
How to make poison arrows, then.
We'll take it.
Brief history of the empire.
Nine pages!
Oh my gosh, no way I leveled up again.
Woohoo!
Mucho texto.
Buff toga feed!
Thank you so much for the five gifted!
Thank you.
I found a book earlier that had 67 pages!
I adored Chibimito, something about her character Popsicle energy that pumps my brain with good vibes.
I felt like this game was good.
But even if I have to use a Chibimito for this game, I felt like...
The game is goofy enough that it suits...
That it fits the vibe.
OMG, you're ET.
Yeah, I'm ET-ing.
Nah.
Let's see.
What should we...
Should we do the same as before?
Agility.
Max.
Speed.
No, not speed.
Endurance.
And strength.
Maybe.
Would be good again.
Let's do it.
We slept an hour.
I don't think there was anything else around here.
Okay.
Chibimito's head is kind of shaped like ET-na's.
Oh!
Who killed that dog?
It wasn't me, was it?
Last time.
Actually, I don't remember.
Was it me?
Free kill.
Hello, sir.
I must stash you a question.
He's ignoring me.
My horse is gonna be over here.
That's not my horse.
My horse...
We're gonna get up to the gates of Kvatch and we're gonna say...
That's my horse!
It's right there!
Why did I go to jail again?
Oh, I think because I was already...
I was a bad girl.
Oops.
That was a bad shot.
Oh my gosh.
Fast.
Oh, fast.
Fast dog.
Fast.
Oh!
Dog is fast.
There we go.
Don't.
You stole a horse and killed a guard.
I borrowed...
...a horse...
...and killed a guard after he mistook my intentions.
But it was self-defense.
Okay, Kvatch is...
Wait, is that a guy over there too?
Oh, I see.
Oh!
I just saw someone running over there!
Um...
I saw...
...a...
This...
Or rather...
Wait.
We...
...came here because...
Why am I here again?
The priest...
...in the chapel of Akatosh.
Yeah, I get sniped, bozo.
Thank you!
Even the notives are...
There it is.
Why isn't the guard doing anything about these guys, huh?
I saw somebody running over there.
I did!
I saw someone running around.
You think there's a guy here?
There's so many camps.
Oh, I see him.
Who saw me?
Oh.
Huh?
What do you mean, huh?
Where are you?
Huh.
So silly.
This stupid bandit.
We're all stupid.
What you got?
Just some wolf pelt?
Come on!
If you're gonna be a bandit, at least be good at your job.
Why aren't you doing anything about these bandits?
Why aren't they doing anything?
There's bandits everywhere.
I'm the one cleaning up the streets here.
Best way to make gold, I found, is to go north...
Go to north of Anvil and...
Here, I'll read that later.
Actually, if you could...
If you could leave that as a comment...
After stream, that would be so helpful.
The horse is back!
We're so back, baby.
We are so back, baby.
Did I even make it to the city before?
I don't think I did.
Oh...
Okay, hold on.
Give me a second, you guys.
I'm gonna change the...
Graphics back.
To what I had them last time.
What I tried before...
Unfortunately...
Is not working out.
That's okay.
That should be...
That should...
Uh-huh.
See?
So, sorry if the graphics are not as great.
But...
For the sake of it just lagging less in general...
I think it would be better.
As I...
As it lags.
But also, there's gotta be some times that it loads in, you know?
Glaim all the plants for the frames.
We should burn down...
We should burn down the forest.
Is this a house?
A sec...
More.
Uh...
More like...
Less.
There's nothing here.
It's empty.
Oh, wait.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
There's gonna be so many dungeons.
We're gonna have to go through a dungeon crawl.
Oh wait.
At some point.
Old wooden door.
Let's see what's in.
Let's just...
Let's just see what's in.
Is that guy naked?
The game just auto-saved.
Oh!
Oh, it's real spooky in here.
What the...
Oh, it's a giant rat.
What do you...
What do you mean one times damage?
Rat.
Why is the rat carrying gold?
I've...
I judged you, rat.
I judged you.
I misjudged you, rat.
This place is spooky scary.
Oh, I think...
I...
Thought I heard something, but I think it was the fire.
Oh!
Nope.
Definitely heard something.
What was that?
Okay.
Very...
Very sneaky of you.
Eat, Tina.
He eats coins.
What is in here?
I will...
Wait.
Save.
New safe.
What am I hearing?
Oh my gosh.
First person, please.
What is that?
That's not your tummy!
Oh!
Sounds like footsteps, but I...
I don't like it!
Let's go this way.
Yeah, we're so close!
I think this is just up here.
Maybe I see it from here.
It sounds like...
I can't tell if they're footsteps or like...
Like a...
Something like banging at a door, you know?
Oh!
So scary!
I'm scared.
I'm not brave at all.
I'm not being brave.
I'm being scared.
I'm being scaredy cat.
Is that a trap or...
Uh...
Yes.
There's a person!
Oh my god.
There's only just people in here.
That's way less scary.
It's an invisible wall?!
No kidding.
Um...
Where are all my arrows at?
That I wasted?
Okay, let's try again.
Oh!
Wait, I did kill them, right?
My arrows?
Look, he's just sleeping.
The floor ate them.
How unfortunate.
Mail bodge.
Ew.
I'm still sneaking through?
I'm still sneaking around?
Okay.
So if I hit this...
Will these hurt me?
No.
Ugh.
You're stupid traps.
Oh my gosh.
Oh shoot.
Oh!
There's many!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I'm trapped.
Uh...
Yeah.
Take you down.
Yeah, take you down.
Ooh!
Ouch!
No, you will know pain.
Oh shoot.
You will know pain.
Give me my arrows back.
Why don't you guys have any...
What's a Marauder?
Why don't you guys carry any loot?
I know I got the wall at one point.
Iron Claymore.
This...
It's...
It's a bandit basically.
Oh.
They just got a fancy name.
I don't need iron arrows.
I don't need your stinky arrows.
Your lesser arrows.
Ugh.
Surely, if anyone else was in here, they would have heard all the commotion though.
Tier 2 bandit.
Uh...
Not at all.
Not at all though.
Because they're...
There's...
Oh!
They got 14 gold!
Okay.
I see her again.
Hehehehe.
Okay.
14 gold.
Sounds like a win to me.
Average.
Average, eh?
I can't tell if I'm getting better or if like...
Because I'm leveling up.
That's increasing...
The easiness.
You know?
The tombs!
Both, I believe.
Oh, okay, okay.
The levels make it easy.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh!
Ah!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Urgh!
Ah!
There are skellies in here.
Why am I going through this?
Why am I in here?
Why did...
I said I did not want to go...
What?
Well, that sounded like someone's tummy.
I said I didn't want to go through a cavern.
Here I am.
For fun.
Okay, let's try and get him again.
Oh!
Come on.
Guy!
I hear the skelly.
I hear him.
Can you come back?
Potential loot.
Shoken desu.
Arigatou gozaimasu!
Zuppa-chan, arigatou gozaimasu!
Come back, please.
Can I activate the gate but not shumairo?
The gate is opened elsewhere.
Oh, okay.
Very good.
Nobody heard that.
I guess.
I hear everything.
Wait, I think that's a skelly.
All the way- Do you see that?
Do you see that shadow?
I wonder...
If I could like, do the best aim ever.
Oh, that totally would have hit him, but you know.
The game hates me.
It's a bone, ma'am.
No, it's a zombie!
It's a zombie!
I see another one, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, even scarier.
Shup!
Oops.
A little too high.
Shup!
We doing stealth, archer?
It's all I know.
He's got some gold on him, though.
He didn't die poor.
Hehehehe.
What is this?
A coffin?
It's so creepy in here.
I don't like the whispers.
I don't like all the whispers and the bugs.
Hot dog!
15 gold!
What whispers?
Don't say that!
Got it!
18 gold!
We're grave robbin'.
Hehehehe.
He he he.
They're not gonna miss it.
Except, don't grave rob me.
Cause, uh...
I would miss mine.
I do need it.
What is it?
F5 is a quick save, right?
F5?
Yes.
Thank you.
I didn't want to accidentally quick load.
That would have been unfortunate.
Hehehehe.
I wonder where that bandit is.
Is this him?
Wait.
Hehehehe.
Oh, stupid.
Okay, let's go.
He, like, went down this way and then disappeared.
Oh!
Nevermind.
He did not disappear!
What are you still doing here?
All your friends are dead.
Okay.
One shot, baby.
Oh, I could've.
I could've taken them down from here.
Well, maybe we can take them down from here.
Right?
One giant rat.
Oh.
Another giant rat.
I like how I only do one time damage.
No, don't move.
I don't see any zombies.
Okay.
Rat.
Big ol' rat.
This place doesn't seem so big.
Or...
Maybe I'm crazy.
I feel like we...
We went into the tomb.
Um...
We're re...
I don't see any other doors.
More gold, though.
I will take all the gold.
More steel arrows!
Is Mint's grave mostly filled with checkies and snake figures?
Who's it to you?
Who's asking?
Uh...
If...
If it is, um...
It's...
It's filled with...
None of those things.
Because those would be really cool.
And then I would have all the grave robbers for real.
Okay, there's really...
Oh wait, I missed a chest.
Oh my gosh.
We got that one.
Okay!
We're done in here.
Skeleton.
Steel War Axe.
What...
When you guys play these games, what's your favorite...
What's your favorite...
Weapon to use?
Oh wait, where did I come from?
Oh, I remember.
How do you like to play?
Bow and magic.
Maybe I should start learning magic.
Magic.
Magic and melee.
Stealth Archer.
So like me.
Bow and dagger.
Oh!
I was about to be like...
Oh my gosh!
This guy!
No, we killed him.
Did I go through here?
No.
Magic is super OP and oblivion.
Maybe I should learn more magic then.
But I've put like...
I've put like no...
Points towards it.
Whoa!
Was this the room?
No.
This is a different room.
Hmm.
Where'd my bow go?
I mean my arrow go.
Lost.
Lost forever.
Some basic spells.
How do you do magic?
Is it like pressing...
1, 2, 3?
On the keyboard?
Or...
Wait, am I going back upstairs?
Where the heck am I?
I'm lost.
Oh!
I went in a circle!
I see.
I know we haven't finished...
I don't like that.
I know we haven't finished this area, but...
I think I want to get to...
The city now.
Wait.
This is the rat I killed.
Oh.
So then up here.
We can come back.
C will cast your equip spells so you can bind spells...
Or items to the 1, 2, 3, etc keys.
I see.
Oh!
I see, I see.
Maybe next time we'll learn magic then.
Next time I play.
I'll focus...
I'll focus on magic next time.
You see?
I...
Shoot.
Gosh, you guys are a pain in my side.
Oh.
I don't have my arrows.
Wait.
There it is.
At least he's not...
Touching my horse!
Oh my gosh.
Gosh!
I got him at point blank range!
He is tough.
Break stuff came on the radio this morning.
I got genuine whiplash when I heard Fred Durr singing and not the code of my ghosty OC.
Your horse has a lot of enemies.
I know, melee archer for real.
You okay, horse?
Yeah.
He's like, I've seen stuff while you were gone.
I've seen stuff, Mito.
I killed your friend and you are next.
You will die in this lovely camp.
Wow.
Wait.
There's gotta be more guys here, no?
There's so many...
Tents.
Nobody else?
Nobody?
There's a big camp, yeah.
Whoa!
You see that?
Wow, what's that over there?
What's that down there?
I'm discovering everything.
And also nothing.
Go touch that.
Yeah?
You don't have to tell me twice.
These bandits are so bad at their job.
They don't...
Band anything.
Wait, what was that?
I guess it was the bed.
They all suck.
It's a glowy rock.
Okay, we're going.
The gold curse.
California girls.
We're undeniable.
Wait, what is that thing?
It's standing there.
Is that a thing standing there?
Well, maybe not.
Are there more bandits here?
I thought it was like a tree person, that thing.
You can travel the world.
It's just a leaf.
Jodestone.
The hero's fate is known when the hero's fame has grown.
Everybody is saying I don't have enough.
I'm too lame.
I'm too lame to buy a house.
I'm too lame to touch a stone.
I moved to California.
And...
I can't even...
Okay, you good ET now?
You good girl?
I moved all the way here.
And what was the point?
They said no clout.
Yeah, actually.
What?
What is that?
Wait, where's my horse?
Wait, there's so much stuff around.
What the heck?
There's just a portal to hell.
Wait, horse?
Where's my horse?
Where'd the camp go?
Wait.
Okay.
Okay, we followed that.
It was like from over.
Wait, that's a dog.
Aw, man.
Ah, that's my horse again.
Horse!
Uh...
I can hear him.
I think that's him.
I don't know where he is.
He's got...
I think he's over here.
Oh, I see him down there.
Silly horse.
Oh!
Hello.
Were you protecting my horse?
Thank you, sir.
Oh.
Or you...
Wait.
Did I do that?
Yes.
Um, any rumors?
That's right.
We gotta go there.
Murdered.
Okay.
What do I do there?
So we...
We did this.
I think this is what I saw from up there.
I was like, oh my gosh.
There's another camp.
But no, it was this one.
Look at...
What is that?
Oh, no!
Wait, there's another camp.
Okay, hold on.
Let's go kill some more people.
I wanna go to...
Um...
The place where Grey Fox is at.
Obviously.
Uh-oh.
Uh...
Come on!
Run while there's still time!
He almost killed you!
God still holds the road.
But it's only a matter of time before they're overwhelmed!
I almost killed you!
I literally just released my button when he came up.
God's blood?
You don't know, do you?
What?
Deidre overran Kvatch last night.
There were glowing portals outside the walls.
Gates to oblivion itself.
There was a huge creature.
Something out of a nightmare.
Title drop.
Came right over the walls.
Blasting fire that swarmed around it.
Killing.
The whole city can't be destroyed.
Go and see for yourself.
Kvatch is a smoking ruin.
We're all that's left, do you understand me?
Everyone else is dead!
Sorry, the delivery is too funny.
How did you escape?
It was Savly and Mattias.
Some of the other guards helped some of us escape.
They cut their way out, right through the city gates.
Savly and says they can hold the road.
No.
No!
I don't believe him!
Nothing can stop them!
If you'd seen it, you'd know!
I'm getting out of here before it's too late.
The toad?
They'll be here any minute, I'm telling you!
Run when you can!
That does not match the face.
Wait, so these are...
Oh, we're in Kvatch.
No, we're in the Gold Coast.
Oh, who are you?
Bolden.
What do you want?
What happened here?
Late at night.
While we were all asleep, the door to oblivion opened.
Deidre came out and set fire to the town.
Many people died, but some got out alive.
I didn't murder any refugees.
They all said bandits.
You mean the priest.
I don't think he made it out of the city.
Very few of us did.
Oh, no.
But Savly and Mattias might know more.
He's in charge of the city guard that are defending the camp.
Okay.
You'll find him at the barricade at the top of the road.
He's still trying to hold what's left of the guard together.
Cool.
Savly and Mattias.
Well, I'm eating some...
Sorry, I'm eating you.
I'm eating some cashews.
Stop talking.
I'm just saying, I'm...
Okay.
I'm going in the tent.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I thought it was a turnip.
Weed him.
We've been hit hard.
But we'll come back.
It looks bad.
It is bad.
But we're tough.
We'll rebuild.
The guards have to clear the ruins first.
That won't be easy.
But I'll be here.
This is my town.
Nothing is driving me out of here.
Weed him, yeah?
Leave me alone.
Oh my god.
You know what?
To be fair, I did wake her up.
So she has the right to say that.
How do I get out?
Oh, the doors.
Oh, the walls look like doors.
And the doors look like walls.
Weed him, yeah?
Who's in here?
So it must be up there.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
So that is a portal to Oblivion.
Do we get to go to Oblivion?
Says I can't open the chest, but...
Wait, what's that?
Oh, just a...
Kvatch shield and sword.
Wait.
I'm not allowed to take those.
What if I'm here to help out?
I could probably...
I could probably just peek.
See, there's nothing in there that I would want anyway.
You'll be going to Oblivion a lot.
Is it like the nether?
Who's in here?
Not good enough to steal.
There was nobody in here, right?
My bad.
What's that?
Fur boots!
Oh, I thought that was a big block of cheese.
Mixed unit tactics.
Codis colonis.
The legions could learn from the unconventional tactics used by the Khajiit in the Five Years' War against Valonwood.
I do my own thing.
I don't need to learn any of your tactics.
Who are you?
Arth...
Athrelor?
Welcome to Kvatch.
We've had a spot of trouble, as you can see.
But I'm open for business.
Oh!
Oh, oh.
Are you?
I really can't tell you what happened.
I'm just lucky to be alive.
I was in my basement.
Suddenly there was a lot of noise and heat.
I couldn't tell you what happened.
I stepped outside.
Oh.
The whole town was on fire.
Smoke.
Everywhere.
I ran for the gate.
I got through the gate.
I kept running through the woods by the light of the fires.
I couldn't tell you what happened.
But here's what happened.
I came back in the morning and Kvatch was gone.
Oh my god.
There was nothing I could do.
I just ran.
If I hadn't, I'd be dead.
Wow.
Wait, why can't I...
You said you're open for business.
You're not letting me sell to you.
Farewell.
Yep, goodnight.
Tucks him in.
I'm gonna tuck you in.
Um...
Yep, you're never...
You're never getting that lockpick back, buddy.
Oh, in the daytime!
I see, I see.
What the...
They took the valuables.
Clearly.
Oh!
Give this lady a proper tent!
She's crawling out.
You picked a bad time to visit Kvatch.
She's so tired she could barely keep her eyes open.
Go look for yourself.
The town is gone.
And most of its people.
Wake up, lady.
The Daedra came out of the gate in the middle of the night.
People who fought, died.
People who ran, they at least had a chance.
Go back to sleep.
I'm so sorry for disturbing you.
Bye!
Oh, did I go in here?
Yes.
Alright.
Perfect.
I believe we've looked through all of these now.
That one guy really booked it, huh?
Kvatch is finished.
There's nothing left.
He looks like he's gonna cry!
Oh!
Nevermind.
Hello.
Come on.
I just can't sleep.
I lie down and close my eyes, but I can't stop thinking about it.
What?
I'm just...
A gate opened and Daedra poured out.
Everybody ran.
Or they died.
I don't know how the fire started, but it burned Kvatch to the ground.
Good day.
Nah, I think it's actually a pretty bad day for you guys.
Okay.
Let's go up there and check it out.
Wait!
Hope is gone.
The Imperial line is dead.
No, my eyes!
My eyes!
Oh my god!
Get that out of my face!
The Imperial line is dead.
And the gods have forsaken us.
Where is our blessing?
Where is our protection?
Where are our gods?
The enemy triumphs.
And we die alone.
He's trying to... he's trying to take me down with him.
Lord Dagon is the enemy.
Dagon?
He is the Prince of Destruction.
And the Daedra are his servants.
The chapel is cast down.
And the faithful, my friends, all dead.
The enemy has won.
And we are destroyed.
Uh-oh.
What?
He seems to be different than your usual self-proclaimed holy man.
Maybe what he says is true.
Prophet?
Who is that?
Wait, I'm asking about something I don't even know.
The attack on the chapel develops just the beginning of an assault on the church itself.
Leave me alone!
Okay.
They're so aggressive.
Whoa.
Okay, let's keep going up.
Wait.
Never mind.
The gold cursed.
Once you party with Minto.
Are we gonna get attacked by some Daedra?
Let's see.
Everyone's so aggro.
I know.
Whoa!
Oh, it looks kinda yummy.
Guys, I wish I could eat lava.
I love a burnt...
Marshmallow.
And it's just...
The most...
Whoa!
It's just the most burnt.
What's happening?
Who are you fighting?
Oh.
Stand back, civilian.
Oh, okay.
This is no place for you.
Get back to the encampment at once.
Rawr!
Uh, what happened here?
We lost the damned city.
That's what happened!
Okay!
It was too much.
Too fast.
We were overwhelmed.
Rawr!
Couldn't even get everyone out.
There are still people trapped in there.
Oh no!
Some made it to the chapel.
Oh.
But others were just...
Run down in the streets.
The Count and his men are still holed up in the castle.
And now we can't even get back into the city to help them.
That damned Oblivion gate blocking the way.
That's inconvenient.
What do we do now?
The only thing we can do.
We'll try to hold our ground.
That's what.
You are three men here!
If we can't hold this barricade, those beasts could march right down and overrun the encampment.
There's the...
There's...
How many people were in this city?
And protect the use of civilians that are left.
It's all I can do now.
How many people were in this city?
If there's only like five people down there.
And three people guarding up here.
You want to help?
You're kidding, right?
Hmm.
If you're serious, maybe I can put you to use.
It'll likely mean your death, though.
City of 20.
Are you sure?
Uh...
Oh.
Oh, quest.
Uh, sure.
I don't know how to close this gate.
But it must be possible.
Don't get your sweatband in a twist.
Because the enemy closed the ones they opened during the initial attack.
You can see the marks on the ground where they were.
With the great gate right in the middle.
I sent men into the gate to see if they could find a way to shut it.
They haven't come back.
Oh.
If you can get in there, find out what happened to them.
I'm just a civilian.
If they're alive, help them finish the job.
If not, see what you can do on your own.
Okay.
The best I can say is good luck.
If you make it back alive, we'll be waiting for you.
Martin.
You mean the priest?
Yeah.
Last I saw him, he was leading a group towards the chapel of Akatosh.
Okay.
If he's lucky, he's trapped in there with the rest of them.
At least...
We need that man!
No, we're going to the nether!
Are we going in?
Oh my gosh.
My home!
My god damn home in flames!
It kills me that I can't get in there and do something!
Why are we here?
We couldn't have been any less prepared for this.
Seems like they came out of nowhere.
There were just so many of them.
If only I had a way to strike back at the enemy.
But we can't leave the barricade until that oblivion gate is closed.
He had such like...
Played us like a god damn fiddle energy!
Some kind of portal to oblivion.
The enemy used them to attack the city.
They appeared outside the walls and Daedra poured out.
Oh my gosh.
They opened one right in front of the city gates.
Until that gate is closed, the best I can do is try to hold these barricades.
Every night I can feel my leg.
Cool.
Good luck.
It's a brave thing you're doing.
Let's get this over here!
This ends here!
Oh.
They killed it.
Good job, everybody.
A stunted scap?
Oh my gosh.
Will you guys hold them off while I go in?
Oh, wow.
Whoa!
Oh.
Oh, my eyes!
Wait, this place kind of sucks.
Oh, my eyes.
Oh, it burns!
It's like I'm staring directly- Look at you, Tina!
Staring directly into the sun!
Here we go!
Eeeh!
Oh.
All you gotta do is walk through it.
Oh,
I see a bunch of things around here, though.
Oh, he's scampering.
Oh, that was way too high.
I saw one over here, too.
Ooh!
Am I at the wrong place, or...?
I don't even care.
They don't even notice.
I don't even notice.
Just a bit.
Oh.
But, like...
All I had to do was go inside.
Uh-oh.
All I had to do was go inside!
I'm not breaking anything?
Okay.
This place is pretty beat up, though.
This must be the Temple of Akatosh, no?
We can go see Martin.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The Chapel of Akatosh.
Okay.
What the...
Oh.
Oh, my God!
We were beginning to fear we were the only survivors.
Yeah, I thought you were gonna draw...
You drew your sword on me!
It...
It all happened so fast.
It was all we could do to round up the survivors and try to get them to safety.
We failed them miserably.
Ah...
Martin, is he here?
Brother Martin?
Yes, he's right over there.
He led a group of us here during the confusion of the attack.
We owe him our lives.
Be seeing you.
Over here!
Oh, I can open these.
What you got in here?
Food?
Hmm.
I just can't sleep.
I lie down and close my eyes, but...
I...
Can't...
Stop thinking about it.
Oh, it's okay.
How did you get in here?
What are you doing here?
I'm here for Martin.
Martin?
He's back there, looking after the other survivors.
Kvatch.
You've seen it.
Kvatch doesn't exist anymore.
They're expressions are so funny.
You too.
I didn't say have a good day.
Repair hammer.
Actually, how is my bow?
Now that I think about it.
54.
I want to try using a repair hammer on it.
But I'm not.
Oh, let's see.
Wait, what's this?
What's that mean?
Enjoy your food.
You too.
Oh, stolen.
It means it's stolen?
Wait, if I use it then.
On my bow.
There we go.
I did it.
Oh, I have so.
One left.
Yay.
Wait.
They can be used more than once.
Oh.
Oh, I see.
I see how it works.
There it is.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Interesting.
Cool.
I learned.
Oh.
I don't want to activate these just yet.
Unless.
There's no.
Bad reason for doing so.
Dang.
I thought we were gonna go here.
And be like, wow.
This is such a bustling city.
So many great things.
What are tongs for?
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Greetings, traveler.
What do you seek?
Nothing.
You too.
Lenka.
I'm sorry.
I don't think I'm gonna be much help.
They're junk.
Oh.
Haha.
Yes.
I followed the priest here.
I'll be safe here, won't I?
They can't come on holy ground, can they?
Yeah.
Good day.
Martin, where'd he go?
Wait, where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
Have you brought help?
We've been trapped here since the Daedra over around the city.
How long have they been...
Oh, wait.
How long have they been stuck here?
Cause like...
Cause...
I've just been like...
I've just been looking for my horse and...
Almost assassinating people.
I was just like...
I was goofing around in...
Skingrad.
And uh...
Who is Sean Bean?
Who's that?
Sean Bond.
Of course I'm in danger.
But I'm needed here.
I can't leave.
I assume you didn't risk your own life to come here to tell me something I already know.
Who are you and what do you want?
Boromir.
Big actor?
Wait, is that the voice actor or Boromir?
Hold on, I Google?
Hello!
It's this guy!
Wait...
I see it!
This is the...
This is literally that meme guy.
One does not simply...
Uh...
Pickpocket.
One does not simply...
Assassinate...
Twin brothers in the night.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You're Martin, right?
Yes.
I'm a priest.
Do you need a priest?
I don't think I'll be much help to you.
It's his voice too?
That's crazy.
I'm having trouble understanding the gods right now.
How did they get such a...
If all this is part of a divine plan.
Star-studded cast.
I'm not sure I want to have anything to do with it.
Hmm...
There's a plan.
We're part of it.
What plan?
What are you talking about?
Actually...
I don't even know what the plan is.
One does not simply walk into oblivion.
Yeah, I walk through it.
What do you possibly know that would help me make sense of this?
Todd the God.
Oh, I...
I forgot that this is a Todd Howard game.
Well...
You are Uriel Septon's son.
Emperor Uriel Septon.
You think the Emperor is my father?
I don't think I know.
I am a priest of Akatosh.
My father was a farmer.
The Emperor knew you were in danger.
You spoke to the Emperor before he died?
And he told you to find me?
Sorry, I'm grabbing more...
...cattle shoes.
Why would I lie to you?
I don't know.
It's strange.
I...
I think you might actually be telling the truth.
What does this mean?
What do you want from me?
I'm a truther.
Come with me to Wayne and Priory.
No.
I'm sorry, but even if what you say is true, I won't abandon these people to their fate.
I'll go with you when we can all leave here together.
I cleared the entrance!
We can all leave!
I...
Nobody's here anymore!
We have to go through the gate?
No kidding.
Need the key.
Block cannot be ticked.
Am I stealing from the church?
Maybe.
But...
Honestly, I deserve the money.
I'm helping them out.
Call it my...
My...
Save the world tax.
Okay, maybe they do need the money.
They can't even afford a bed.
They can't even afford proper beds.
Hmm.
Uh...
I still don't feel guilty though.
Oh, never mind.
See?
They have two proper beds.
They're fine.
Oh, I was gonna say I like how just randomly the rain comes through, but...
There's actually a hole in the ceiling.
That's crazy.
Okay.
I'll go, uh...
Back outside.
If that's what you want me to do.
You're sending me back out there with the demons.
Yeah?
Okay.
No one...
No one's gonna help or...
Alright.
Let's go into the nether.
I gotta get my arrows back.
What is this thing?
I...
What is this?
How?
Oh my god, it's kinda cute.
It's just a lizard.
Real dinosaur.
Oh!
Oh, hi.
That was a nice girl.
They got gold.
Who else got gold?
I don't know why do people keep gold in their barrels.
The good old days of...
Keeping gold...
Oh, oh, this is the top of the chapel.
That's crazy.
Wait.
Okay.
To the nether!
You don't...
I keep my gold in my barrels.
That's what I'm saying.
Not enough people are keeping their gold in their barrels anymore.
Okay.
Let's go.
Into oblivion.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
My first time here!
Oh, they already brought...
The hospitality team.
Uh-oh.
Woo!
In those fire!
Is that a friend or...
I think that's a friend.
You're human!
What if it was a...
That's a bandit?
Thank the nine.
I never thought I'd see another friendly face.
The others...
Taken...
They were taken to the tower.
The tower...
It's alright.
What's going on?
Captain Matthias sent us in to try and close the gate.
We were ambushed, trapped, and picked off.
How... where were you?
They managed to escape.
But the others are strewn across the bridge.
They took Minion off to the big tower.
You've got to save him.
I'm getting out of here.
No, no, no.
Hold on.
Yeah, yeah.
You're right.
I can't just leave poor Minion to his fate.
Minion.
If he's still alive, we've got to try to save him.
Or I'll be the way.
Yeah, you are gonna abandon your friend.
Let's find Minion and get out of here.
So true.
Nice.
Okay.
We're gonna find that guy.
Let me get my arrows back.
My steel arrows.
They're worth a lot.
Uh...
The bridge?
How do I open it up?
Oh, it's sick.
I should make this an interactive quest.
You know what?
You're right.
We still have the Paranoid.
Uh...
Break the siege.
Wait.
No, this one.
Breaking the siege of Kvatch.
There we go.
Where did that guy come from?
Why are you helping me out?
Where were you hiding?
Any guys over here?
No?
Whoa!
It's a body on fire.
I'm just taking it all in.
Touch that plant.
What plant?
I don't see any plant.
Hang on.
This plant?
Oh, blood grass.
I don't know if I want to take that.
I don't know if...
Oh, always gather lots of materials in oblivion.
I've harvested the blood grass.
Nice.
Wait, hold on.
I want to get a good shot of E-Tina here.
Oh, she looks evil!
Oh, no.
Sorry.
I thought that was a fiery imp behind her.
I feel like...
Tina, behind you!
Evil E-T.
Okay, I'm one in front of the gate, too.
I feel...
Oh, my God!
Oh, she looks so evil!
Okay.
Across the bridge we go!
To the bridge we go!
Activate the gate...
Oh, uh...
Uh...
Can I help a ghost out?
Where is the gate opening?
How do we open the gate?
Is it this?
Huh?
Oh!
What the?
How did I miss you?
Wait!
Oh!
Uh, good job!
Good job!
Ooh, Dad.
This is my buddy.
Uh...
Illand.
Where is the...
I'm just gonna keep looking...
Wait, what is that?
Is that a...
Uh...
I don't like the looks of that thing.
I'm gonna shoot it down?
Never mind.
But I see a little...
A little scallywag there.
Oh.
Let's stick together!
Oh my god.
I don't...
What?
Is it not a...
Seed?
Oh, the crouch for sneak bonus.
You're so right!
How could I forget?
You're right, you're right.
Cause that's how I get my three times, baby.
Ew!
I'll take the stinky...
The stinky...
Grass?
Oh my gosh!
All of our friends are over there!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Touch the sack.
Fleshy pod!
Oh!
It was actually stacked.
Can you unsuccessfully...
Harvest things?
The sacks have loot.
Good to know.
L-l-l-lava!
Maybe up in here?
Oh.
This is not an entrance.
Don't follow me.
Me too.
Guys...
Am I blind?
Where is the...
How do you activate the entrance?
How did you guys do it?
I'm gonna ask him.
What's the plan?
Follow me.
Let's go this way, I suppose.
I wanna go see what that burning body is anyway.
I hear something...
That sounds like...
It's all like...
Oh, what?
Is that it right there?
Just follow the path.
Oh!
Are you okay?
Pickpockets.
Yes!
Must have been the way...
Wow!
Cirque du Soleil.
Can I die in the lava?
Oh!
There we go.
Yes!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Wow!
That was fast!
Yo, Kaitina!
Why is she looking at him like that?
What?
I think they have chemistry.
Are you guys seeing it too?
Look at the way they just...
stare at each other.
I think they have chemistry.
Alright.
Onward.
Another flesh pod.
We're being very sneaky.
I think I hear something there.
It sounds like something walking.
Huh?
What is...
What is it?
It's gone now.
Did you hear that?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
These...
These stones are made of...
Of...
Foam or something.
Oh shoot.
Is that their idea of a trap?
Or...
Oh nice.
Oh!
I wasted it!
No!
Shoot the rocks.
Now that arrow is now...
That arrow went...
Oh...
It went back through the portal.
I'll wait for that guy to show back up.
I'll be able to get him.
I can get him.
Maybe.
Oh!
Flesh pods.
Nice.
Ooh!
Bound boots.
My speed!
Oh!
They drained my speed!
Hello.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I still got him.
I thought he said...
Fuck him up!
Fuck!
Nice.
Oh my god!
This place really is the nether.
Watch out.
Oh my god!
Don't let the trees touch you.
Everything's evil here.
There was a guy up here.
I know there was.
Can I kill these?
Or...
Let's try.
No.
I think I just lost an arrow.
Okay.
It was a good experiment.
You can harvest them?
Shut up.
Oh!
I can't take the whole thing though.
My sneak has increased.
Looking around.
Making sure I don't get attacked.
And...
The hat looks like it should be like...
Like a secret entrance or something.
You know what I mean?
The hat looks like it's blow...
Like you can blow it up.
I know there was a guy up there.
Wait, what is this?
Nothing.
Um...
Okay, we're heading the right way.
We are, we are.
Where are you?
Whoa.
Oh, where are I...
That's a great question.
But the...
The red arrow goes to here.
So we're just gonna keep going that way.
Looking around for any...
Critters, creatures.
Daedra.
As they are called.
Like...
So.
Oops.
Hiya.
I wish I could...
Maybe if I like put my bow away.
What is that?
What?
Did you...
Where?
It does work?
Oh, okay, okay.
How can you see the land mines?
Oh my gosh.
This guy is just casually on fire.
Nice!
Those mines hurt?
Okay, okay.
We gotta...
We gotta be careful.
But look!
There's a door!
And the symbol of the game.
Oblivion.
Looking for any mines.
And any guys.
I don't see anything, so let's go onwards.
There you are, buddy.
Let's go.
Inside.
Oh god.
Oh yeah!
Oh no!
Uh...
That's kinda crazy.
I'll take that.
We don't want them...
We wanna take their...
We wanna rob them of whatever they're worth, you know?
Oops.
I'm cut.
What the...
Where'd my arrows go?
He stole them!
What?
Oh my god!
Ouch!
Good job, buddy.
I didn't even see that thing.
It consumed...
Okay.
We gotta go this way.
We're following that red arrow.
We're doing the quest, everybody.
We're doing it!
This is quite...
The location.
This is a trapler!
Dekor!
Okay, no.
Just Dekor.
Trap or Dekor.
Oh.
Friend?
Fuck.
Deidre Har!
Wait, it kinda sells for a pretty penny.
What's my...
Let's see, my weight at...
Oh wow!
We actually improved so much.
Not friend.
It was like such a cool entrance, though.
I thought that maybe...
I don't know.
I don't know what I was thinking.
Oops.
Sheath thy sword.
Illend.
I have sneak bonus.
That's...
Blood fountain?
I don't know what that did, but I feel powerful.
Wait.
Fifteen.
Aha!
Door to the blood feast!
Wait, where do these go then?
If that's the blood feast...
Blood feast?
Just the hall?
Boo!
We don't want to go to some boring hall.
We want to go to the blood feast.
Hahaha!
Blood for the blood feast.
Oh, it's just this room again.
Oh my gosh, my eyes.
Oh, it really is like just staring directly into the sun.
We gotta go around it.
What?
I don't know why they said specifically that door.
This one.
Corridors of dark salvation!
Hahaha!
Who's naming these?
I hope the bitrate is a bit better...
This time playing.
I upped the bitrate as well, so...
We must go up.
But what's over here?
I'm just curious.
See, look!
That looks like you could break it!
No!
My sneak is going crazy in here.
Hello?
Arrow?
Arrow.
What the?
Why isn't it aiming?
Why?
What the?
Is it...
No, there's no way I'm out...
Wait.
There's no way I'm out of arrows.
Wait, why aren't they equipped though?
No way!
I'm almost out of arrows?
Out of steel arrows?
I have a lot of iron ones, but I've been using the steel ones because they're better.
Just use the...
I think an iron might be good for now.
I've been...
It's been eating my steel arrows like crazy!
And now I'm almost out.
That sucks.
That sucks so bad.
Hey, other guy.
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
You don't see me.
Where'd you go?
Oh, there you are.
Ah!
No more fancy arrows.
It's okay.
We don't need them.
We're too good.
We don't need no stinking arrows.
Stinking...
Well, no.
That's a lie.
We need arrows.
We don't need no stinking...
fancy arrows.
But I still...
I feel like I've been...
Worship.
We could just...
Chill at the bench.
Um...
I feel like I've been picking them up.
No.
It's kind of crazy that I'm almost out.
Would you like to join me?
Nah.
You look so happy.
Looks like my cat.
Whenever I pet paws, she makes this face.
I love seeing I see her little bottom teeth.
Yeah.
Looks like my cat.
Wait.
This way.
We almost went...
We almost went to the citadel.
No, no, no.
Oh, it needs a key anyway.
No, no.
Oh.
Oh, no.
This guy fell for his own trap.
What the heck is this place?
They kill their own friendly fire.
We need to go here.
What a bozo.
Whoa.
Look, I can see even guys from here.
I can see my house from here.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
This is crazy.
Look at that view.
I missed a guy.
I saw him walking.
Reaper's sprawl.
Wait, you don't have a hat.
Oh.
Is that...
Is that our guy?
Oh, sorry.
Uh, where?
Quickly.
I'm coming.
Sorry.
I just...
I got distracted.
Oh my god.
I don't know how my...
Oh.
You got him.
Over here.
Quickly.
I don't know what just happened with my...
With my bow.
Again.
We got all our stuff.
They took your clothes!
Quickly.
There's no time.
You must get to the top of the large tower.
The sigil keep, they call it.
That's what keeps the oblivion gate open.
Find the sigil stone, remove it, and the gate will close.
Hurry.
The keeper has the key.
You must get the key.
Minion.
I got the key.
Take the key.
Get to the sigil keep.
And find the sigil stone.
It's the only way.
Don't worry about me.
There is no time.
Get moving!
He's so selfless.
Actually, he probably feels safer in here, huh?
That guy doesn't have to do any work now.
Okay.
We're going.
Wait, what's down here?
Oh.
I didn't mean to do that.
What's down here?
I'm checking it out real quick.
It's kind of, it's kind of deep.
Wait.
Oh.
I was going to say, where's my friend?
What are you doing up there?
He is practicing his witchcraft, I think.
We'll just let him...
I don't know.
No!
There is no way.
Wait.
Oh.
As soon as I saw that they had a connection, I should have known.
I don't know what this does, but...
Oh my god.
His body is gonna...
43.
Where are we going?
Free armor?
Oh wait, it's not so heavy at all, actually.
Take his clothes.
Should I be here?
Wait.
I don't know where I need to go, actually.
Quests.
Let's reach the sigil stone.
Yeah, we want to go up, but it didn't go...
It can't go up.
Hmm.
Yeah, I think we gotta go back out the way we...
It just works.
I hear something screaming.
Okay.
Well, rip our friend, I guess.
I was so sad for him.
He was such a good help, though.
He really found the guys when I couldn't see them.
Oh, man.
No, he wasn't.
Yes, he was.
He was.
He was a good help.
Okay.
We got that key.
So I imagine it's to...
This door.
Yes, sir...
Nope.
Yes, siree.
Sigil keep key.
I'm sneaky.
Oh my god.
Can I ever loot this guy?
Oh, it says empty.
I'm so stupid.
Okay, in there, but what's over here?
Just a little tad...
A tad bit of exploration.
Oh.
Yes.
Why are all these guys dead to their own traps?
Door to the blood feast.
I still miss my three legion chads from the Kavaj siege.
Oh gosh, I can't see anything in this room.
I could be ambushed at any moment.
What?
That looks like a human though.
Oops.
Oh shoot.
Oh, he just summoned something.
Oh.
They placed the traps very well.
Oh yeah, they did.
Let's take that.
We'll just take all the potions.
I'm gonna take the heart.
Oh, restores health.
That's nice.
Summon the gentle gust.
So we got some toughies in here, huh?
Ruined portal to the blood feast.
Wait.
Oh, this is where I need to go.
No?
Oh, what is?
Oh.
Okay.
Let's go.
It's quiet.
Oh my gosh.
Fleshy pod.
Is this thing alive?
Or...
It's got little chains on it.
There we go.
Um...
We gotta go this way, but...
The punished.
Ew.
Well, if the gate closes...
And I'm in here...
Um...
How do we get...
Home?
Punished.
Venom.
How do the daedra hearts taste like?
Like a...
Like a big ol' raspberry.
Delicious.
I'll take some more.
Wait, I can...
I can pick this.
This doesn't require a key.
Oh.
Dang it.
Aw, man.
I thought I was gonna do like the cool thing.
What is this anyway?
Okay, let's go back.
Get in.
You pick the lock with the key.
They never saw it coming.
They were like, what?
How did he get in with such ease?
Such...
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh my gosh.
Ow, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oof.
I gotta be careful with those guys.
They're tough.
Almost there.
Wait.
Eh?
Ah?
Wait.
Eh?
Ah?
Wait.
Dagoth, you're welcome to the heart chamber here in Red Mountain.
Wait, go here?
Both doors lead to the same place.
Oh, no kidding?
I used the key?
Was it a loop?
Oh!
It was just a loop.
Oh my gosh, I was here.
Oh!
Sneakery!
Sneak mastery increase!
Nice!
Is this like the... the... the sigil?
Do I go on the meatball?
Nasty.
There's nobody in here, I think.
Wait.
On this?
I didn't even realize this is a staircase.
Wow!
Poco, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, we can level up too.
Raymack, thank you so much for the 5 gift of thank you!
Oh, I do need to go into here.
Just kidding.
Thank you for the... gift of thank you!
Oh, I think I need to go up for it.
It's at the top, yeah.
And if you're wondering why I'm still sneaking around...
Because I want that sneak bonus.
Wait.
Somebody saw me, but...
I don't know from where or whom's or where.
Somebody's... trying to attack me.
Um...
They're on the staircase?
They are?
No?
Oh?
Ah!
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
Hey!
Where did he come from?
Oh, I must have been really blind to him.
Holy moly.
I must have been so blind to him!
Wait.
Actually, we should put on our new... armor, right?
What did we get from... chainmail boots?
Aww, say goodbye to our... Oh, everybody who came in!
This is E.T.na.
Definitely not E.T.
in a wig.
Ooh!
She's looking good!
What else did we get?
This thing.
Thanks for being you.
You rock!
Thank you!
But I don't like to put on hats because it ruins her hair.
And we got our... Oh, we changed our boots.
We were wearing the gold trim shoes.
Probably better to wear actual armor, huh?
Oh, I see that guy.
I see that guy over there.
In the shadows.
Wait.
Can I kill you first?
Nice!
Take that chest piece to sell.
Wait.
The one that the guy had?
I wonder if I would be over-encumbered with a... This guy?
Oh, wait.
He doesn't have anything.
Oh, in here, maybe?
This one?
Wow!
It is worth a lot, but it's also pretty heavy.
Am I over-encumbered?
Close!
This is the way we all play Oblivion.
Is it really?
Or are you just saying that?
If you save the castle in this town's mission, you get a special enchanted version of the armor.
Really?
E.T.na kind of looks like you with a suntan.
I don't tan.
My ectoplasm burns.
Oh, man.
Okay.
We're gonna go up in just a moment.
Honestly, my sneak is, like, going crazy right now.
Everybody, wear your sunscreen, okay?
Wear your sunscreen.
You mortals.
Oh!
Wait.
I kind of want this, though.
Drop some random junk.
What can we... It's only... It's literally one.
This thing is so heavy.
I can get rid of these, huh?
Uh... Left ship.
That's so heavy.
Sword by weight.
True.
My long sword...
Is this better than the long sword?
No.
But I think I'm okay now if I take it.
Whoa!
No, I'm not okay.
I'm over-encumbered.
Let's see.
A lot of hearts.
I took a vase.
It only sells for 3 gold.
I'm a cucumber.
Cucumbered.
Hmm.
I got some raw... Oh, some rat meat I can get rid of.
Um... I got a lot of potions.
But they're really way nothing.
You know what?
I could get rid of the swords.
Switch out the swords.
Maybe...
I can get rid of my shoes.
I'll get rid of my shoes.
Click on the snowball tome.
Yes.
Like, can I get rid of it now?
The dogs are out.
No, we're wearing some new steelies.
Oh, I can get rid of it.
Okay.
But I could sell it.
For 21 gold.
It's good to think about the weight value ratio.
Lots of low weight items with high value are better than a few heavy items.
Yeah, I know.
Drop the ale?
Oh, so true!
Oh, I already took it.
That's right.
Here we go!
Woohoo!
Is it timed?
I'm scared.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Am I over encumbered?
Oh.
Close an oblivion gate.
Oh!
I have closed the gate by taking the sigil stone that anchors it within oblivion.
I should tell Salvian Mathias that the way into Kvatch is now open.
Uh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
No one else made it.
Hahaha!
Um.
It wasn't my fault.
Like, actually, for once.
Oh, nice.
Some more steel arrows.
How much is the stone worth?
What?
Priceless.
I just saved it.
Shut up.
Hahaha!
You can do it.
This is our chance to launch a counter-attack.
I need you to come with us.
You've got far more combat experience than these men.
How- how is that possible?
I can wait, but not for long.
We've got to move quickly before they have a chance to barricade the city gate.
Okay.
I'm ready.
For Kvatch!
Oh, we're running?
Uh, we're running?
Hahaha!
This guy's...
We're fine, guys.
We got this.
Sigil stones can be used to enchant items.
Each one has a unique effect.
Oh.
I have entered the ruined city of Kvatch with Savlian, Matias, and his men.
We must clear the southern plaza before the survivors in the chapel can be rescued.
Oh, they all respawn.
That sucks.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not okay.
I'm not fine.
I lied.
I said I'd be fine.
Oops.
We did it!
We're never going to take me to drop.
Oh, oh, my bad.
Ooh, her hair was... yep.
Seal helmet.
Well, it's worth a pretty penny, huh?
Um... I didn't even do anything.
Mainly because I got scared.
Good value helmet, yeah.
We'll want to go back for that.
For sure.
If I jump in these places, can I get out?
Wait, can I go up here?
I can.
There was only four little lizards and then... nothing else in this whole place?
This is the whole city?
This is the entire city.
You're telling me.
Whoa!
Somebody's head.
We wiped the bastards out.
It's safe to pull those people out of the chapel.
Let's get in there and make sure they're all right.
Yeah, they're probably fine.
This is only the beginning of the battle for Kabach.
Oh, oh, really?
Oh.
We can discuss the next phase once the civilians are safe.
Oh, okay.
Yes, only... oh, there's more?
Hello, everybody.
Report, soldier.
Sir, we're all that's left.
Barak Indian, myself, and these civilians.
That's it?
There's no one else?
There were others, sir, but they refused to stay put.
We tried to convince them it was dangerous, but they left anyway.
I guess they didn't make it.
Oh.
Very well.
The area outside the chapel has been cleared, and these people need to be taken to safety.
Escort them to the camp south of here at once.
But, sir, I want to help fight.
You will, soldier.
Once they're secure, get back here immediately.
We'll need every available blade, and there'll be plenty of fighting to go around.
Sir, yes, sir.
Civilians, it's time to move out.
Let's go.
Civilians.
Let's go see them.
Who's this guy?
Where did you come from?
Where's the priest?
Wait, where's the priest?
Hello?
Future?
I'm just lucky to be alive.
You know, your friend did that before he fell to his death.
Get back on the ground.
Stay grounded, soldier.
Now what?
We've done it.
I can't believe it.
His face.
I didn't really think this would work.
Maybe we do have a fighting chance.
Oh, yes.
We're not done.
Not even close.
This was only the first step.
If this town is to be ours again, we'll need to get inside the castle.
You've come this far with us.
We've done it.
Will you go further?
If we're truly going to succeed, I'll need much more of your help.
We've done it.
I warn you, though.
What we've seen so far is nothing compared to the battle that likely awaits us.
Oh, really?
Take a few moments to catch your breath and think it over.
When you're ready, let me know and we'll get underway.
Okay.
I gotta go sleep.
All I need is one hour.
Don't mind me.
Look at him.
Look at him with his special eyes.
I left all the doors open.
They probably don't know that I robbed the place, though.
No?
Level five!
Woohoo!
Let's see.
Let's keep doing our agility.
That's important for us.
Why do I only have...
That's gonna bother me.
Strength is carrying capacity.
Yeah, I know.
I know, I know.
I don't think I'll do strength right now, though.
Hold on.
Whoop.
Determines how quickly...
Oh, the magicka.
That's right.
Endurance...
Is our health, which is good.
You need the strength to collect that helm.
True!
Oh my gosh.
Maybe I should go sell my stuff before we talk to him.
You know?
Maybe...
We'll do the...
Wait.
Let's do like...
Let's do like that.
Yeah.
And then...
We'll go sell our stuff.
And then we'll talk to him.
Let's go...
Wait.
What time is it?
Let's wait...
For what...
Let's actually...
I think we can just run there.
And then we'll wait...
While we're there.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
You scared me.
Just follow the captain's orders.
Okay.
Let's get this.
And then we're gonna sell it.
Wait.
Oh my god!
Where...
Where the heck did you come from?
Wait.
I could sell this.
Am I over-encumbered?
Yeah.
Oh.
Like a lot?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Uh.
Ugh.
I just need the helmet.
Ha ha ha.
Ugh.
Okay.
I can't do this.
Where is it?
It'll take us five years to get to the camp.
Wait, did these ha... Oh, I already looted these things, didn't I?
Yeah,
my noodle legs.
What?
What do you mean, top?
What were you guys saying at the top?
Oh, who are you guys?
What do you seek?
What are you doing?
I'll never forget him.
He saved as many as he could that terrible night.
If only they'd listen and stay with us in the chapel.
Take care.
Bye-bye.
Talking about the list, you're fine.
Oh, oh, I get what you mean.
The mace was at the top of the list.
Oh, thank you, guys.
Heh heh heh.
Heh heh heh heh heh heh.
Heh heh heh heh heh heh heh.
Heh heh heh heh heh.
Hee hee.
Heh heh heh heh.
T-tot-tot-tuh, t-tot-tot.
Look at us go.
We're running.
I'm gonna invest in speed.
Eventually.
Wait, where's the camp?
Oh, a little bit.
Okay, I don't remember this.
Wee, woohoo!
What?
Oh, they're all down here now!
Oh, this guy, right?
That's so cute that they're all in the little village now.
Hello!
Am I more famous, popular now?
When's your store open?
Bye.
Well, let me sell things, please.
Honestly, I should be able to steal whatever the heck I want right now and...
get away with it.
It's the smell, really.
Smoke and fire.
Something worse.
In the ruins.
Gods.
Okay.
Maybe I'm gonna wait...
one hour.
Okay.
Most stores open at eight.
I just can't sleep.
I lie down and close my eyes.
It's the smell, really.
Everybody's talking about the smell.
Imagine the smell.
You've done us a great service, stranger.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
We are all grateful.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh my god, still!
Be seeing you.
Yeah, you will.
In one hour, exactly.
They open at eight.
Okay.
Imagine the smell.
The boss is finished.
It's the smell, really.
Smoke and fire.
Something worse.
In the ruins.
Gods.
I don't even notice anymore.
I guess you can get used to anything.
I'm just lucky to be alive.
Oh, they're so funny.
Okay.
The smell.
You think they're going to talk about the smell again?
Anybody got that smell?
The boss is finished.
There's nothing.
Happy to finally catch you live.
Have fun, Mito.
Thank you!
Wait.
Where is he?
Oh my god.
He left the tent!
I'm just lucky to be alive.
Oh, there you are.
You've done us a great service, stranger.
We are all grateful.
Yeah, now let me...
I thought you were...
Why?
Oh, you don't like me even though I just saved your ass?
I'm angry.
I wanna stay angry.
Take care.
That anger keeps me going.
This...
Try the oraker?
You closed the gate.
That's the first good news in a long time.
Oh!
Bartering!
Oh my gosh, thank you guys.
What can I interest you in?
Wait, what's our...
What's our disposition at?
11!
Okay.
Um...
Hello, Batool.
What?
She only has 200 gold.
It's okay.
We gotta get rid of some stuff, you know?
She likes a good joke.
You can't scare me.
Don't make me laugh.
I have to remember how to do this.
I like that.
A lot.
Yeah.
Oh, shoot.
I messed up.
Oh, wait.
No, she likes this.
It's good of you to say so.
Nice.
Okay.
Cool.
We got her up quite a bit.
Uh...
Let's do it again.
Blah, blah, blah.
What up, boar?
Uh...
Oh, that's great.
Oh, no!
Wait, I messed up.
You can't scare...
Okay, let's try again.
Oh...
Where, where, where, where?
You're a big, fat liar.
Oh...
Thank you.
Oh, okay.
Okay, we got some more.
How's it going again?
You're doing fine?
Thank you.
Okay.
You can't scare me.
It's not the best, but...
Oh, no.
That's really...
You're a big, fat liar.
Oh, my gosh.
We were at 70.
You're a big phony.
You're a big, fat liar.
How nice.
Is that...
That's real.
Oh, so close!
So stinking close.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Uh, shoot.
That's correct!
Don't make me laugh.
You're wasting your...
You're too kind.
Woo-hoo!
All right.
I get it.
We did it!
Nice.
Okay.
Let's, uh...
Let's ask her.
I don't like to talk about it.
I don't remember much.
I woke to screaming and fire.
I ran.
I was lucky.
I survived.
My friends weren't so lucky.
Aww.
Anyway, uh, how much money you got?
Now look at my wares.
I'm sure there's something to suit you.
Yes.
I'm sure.
All right.
Let's sell like this.
Wait.
Oh, haggle, haggle, haggle.
What if I did...
What if I did 60% of value?
I can't do that.
55.
Final offer.
I can't afford to do that.
50.
Final offer.
You've gotta be kidding.
Uh...
F...
45.
Final offer.
You don't expect me to make that deal, do you?
40.
Our disposition went down.
Final offer.
You need to make a better offer.
I appreciate your business.
I don't.
Please.
Go on.
Oh, please.
You're too kind.
I like that.
You're full of it.
I see.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
More...
More bartering, please.
Have a look around.
You won't find better prices in old town.
Thank you.
Okay.
38.
Final offer.
You're trying to drive me out of business.
35.
Final offer.
Oh, my God.
It worked.
Wait, let's just get rid of some of the...
Oh, gosh.
Resist poison on self.
It's so heavy.
I just want to get rid of it.
That's a fair deal.
Is it?
I just noticed I have two steel long swords.
When did I get a second one?
Why is this one so much more heavy?
That seems a fair price.
Oh, long sword, short sword.
Oh, I can't read.
Just dump them on her.
We'll keep the short sword.
Okay.
We should be...
Oh, wait.
Here's some nuggets.
What?
That's more than I'd usually pay.
Is it now?
Okay.
Oh, she must really like ice, huh?
The claymore is heavy.
It is, but...
I feel like I could get a better price for it, no?
Short damage...
Short damage determined by agility.
Long damage determined by strength.
So, yeah.
Keeping the short...
Sword would be much better for me.
You have a lot of money.
What?
I have pennies.
I gotta be able to buy a house.
Just sell it.
Okay.
Come back and see me again.
Wait.
What was it that I was wanting to...
Buy?
Have a look around.
You won't find better prices in all Tamriel.
Maybe nothing.
Steel arrows.
Yeah, but...
She's got none.
We see.
Thank you.
I've looked everywhere.
Perhaps she's still in Kavach.
In a basement.
Hiding?
It's possible.
Or maybe she got out and she's looking for you too.
Kavach is finished.
There's nothing left.
Everybody is such a downer.
Okay.
Alrighty, guys.
We go back up.
Hello.
They literally lost their homes.
Yeah, and like all...
All 20 people that were living in this kingdom.
Does this count as a kingdom?
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
And now we get to see the city in the daylight.
So that's fine.
Ooh, it's...
Dusty.
It's dusty in here.
Can we go in...
Woah.
Alright.
It's a county.
I also wonder the smell.
Are you ready to go?
We need your help getting to the castle, but we need to move soon.
Uh...
Yeah.
I knew you'd be up to it.
Our goal is the castle gate.
Okay.
We should be able to use this door to get out to the plaza in front of the castle gatehouse.
You know the drill.
Stick close and keep your eyes open.
Let's move out!
Autobots!
Okay.
I'm gonna sneak, cause it gives me more damage.
I think he sees me.
Snipe!
Oh.
Uh...
Snipe!
Oh, I did get him.
Holy cow!
Oh!
Who just shot that at me?
What's that at me?
Actually, I'm not quite sure.
Did we...
Clear it?
Is it cleared?
Clear!
Hold.
Take that.
The hearts sell.
For good amount.
Um...
I'm checking the area?
The surrounding area?
Just in case?
I think it's clear.
They're tasty too.
I know.
They taste like raspberry.
I think you're good.
I think...
Oh!
Wait.
What are they doing?
Where did they go?
I just saw him run into here?
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Where did that man go?
Where...
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Where's the rest of the men?
Why did that happen?
Where did he go?
Oh!
I hope the...
Rain isn't destroying the bitrate too much.
Leathered laced pants just sounds way too sexy.
Oh!
There he is!
We're not good.
Where are you...
Oh!
There's someone...
Firing fireballs from above.
I think?
Or...
From...
From somewhere?
Oh!
Boss, get there.
That's an enemy gunship.
Wait, where...
You're alive, right?
Where is it?
Am I...
I'm so blind.
I can't see anything in this game.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I saw him!
He just walked past.
You saw him too?
Oh, wait, wait, I see him?
I'm just gonna go for it.
Oops.
Just a little bit.
Oh, come on.
Okay, I'm just gonna talk to him.
Damn it!
This is no good!
The gates are locked.
And the only way to open them is from within the gatehouse.
Oh.
We can't open that gate from out here.
The only mechanism for raising it is inside the gatehouse.
Where's the gatehouse?
And the only way to get into the gatehouse now would be through the passage at the north guardhouse.
But that's always kept locked.
Oh, well, you're talking to him.
Hurry and find Baruch Inion.
Who?
He should be back in the chapel.
And should still have the key to the guardhouse.
Well, I was gonna say, you're talking to a master lockpick.
Once you've got it, get to the guardhouse.
Find the passage and open that gate.
Then we can get inside the castle and secure it.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Get moving!
We can't do a thing until you get those gates open!
Okay!
I'm going!
It's already night time again.
Crazy.
Get moving!
I...
I'm a lockpicking champion!
Uh, follow me!
Okay.
Cool.
Are you...
Wait.
Oh, you, you, you.
I'm just waiting for Captain Mattias to give the order.
Finally.
A chance to fight them!
The Chads came in.
Yes, I have it.
Why?
Give it to me!
I needed to get to the...
Oh, yeah, his orders.
You do the guard one little favor and suddenly you think you're Mattias' best friend.
You probably couldn't find it on your own.
I'm coming with you.
If we make it, I'll open the door for you.
Oh, he's jealous.
I've still got some fight left in me!
Oh!
Okay.
Is it this one?
Where did he go?
Wait.
Oh, here.
Okay.
He's a little jealous.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, yoy, yoy, yoy!
Remember me!
Do your worst!
Hey, hey, hey!
Watch where you're swinging that thing.
Gosh.
You might wanna switch to short sword.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
I don't know.
Empty.
It says empty.
I don't know why I click.
Okay.
Got your arrows out?
Yeah, he's ready.
Okay, so we go...
This!
This way.
Hold on.
This is my first time coming down here.
Are those bones?
I think they're rocks.
I thought you had some fight left in you, buddy.
Yeah, who needs a short sword?
Oh!
This is the part where you fall down and bleed to death!
That the best you can do?
Oops.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, golly.
They can't see me at all.
Hahaha!
I thought mud crabs were fearsome than you.
I thought mud crabs were fearsome.
I love that I'm...
I'm crouched, so I'm like...
Giving more damage.
Wait.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't...
I literally can't hit anything.
I'm so bad at this.
Hahaha!
I'm so stealthy, they run away from...
They just run around me.
More?
You got him?
Oh, no you don't.
You okay?
Just a...
Just a little bit of a burn.
I'm trying to get the arrows back.
This guy dropped steel arrows.
He's great.
Iron arrow.
You know who hit that one.
Hahaha!
Okay.
Let's go.
For the emperor!
But I kinda wanna, like, take the stuff from the homes, you know?
Okay.
Okay, he's okay.
He's ignoring us completely.
Oh.
I said empty.
My bad.
For...
Hold on.
Let me get it.
Oh.
Oopsie!
Sorry!
Oh, my God.
I accidentally hit...
Uh, friendly fire.
Are you okay?
I accidentally friendly fired him.
But...
Let's take all of it.
I actually...
Maybe I should let them do all the work.
Because then I can take all their steel arrows.
Free arrows, baby.
Oh.
Whoa!
Hey, team?
Aren't we just such a good team?
Deidre running away.
I know, they're such cowardly...
Oh, wow.
Oh!
Flawless Pearl!
I've got so many potions.
I should use... I should... I should use them... eventually.
At some point.
How much further is it?
Oh, it's over here?
This is it?
That it?
The passageway?
Potion seller.
I'm gonna become the potion seller at this point.
Hold on, hold on.
I wanna see what's over here.
Oh.
Wait, over...
Oh!
Oh, I forgot to...
Thank you!
I forgot to crouch.
Was this...
Where I wanted to go see?
Actually, I'm so lost.
Guys, I'm lost.
Wait, we can...
You know what?
Let's... go.
Let's go in.
Let's... let's just...
Uh...
We came from...
This way.
Yeah, so this is where I wanted to...
Look.
And I looked.
Now we can go down the hatch.
Oh.
Hello?
This is it.
The entrance to the passage is right here.
I'll unlock it for you.
Best of luck.
Bag for him.
You got it?
Oh, thank you.
Down the hatch.
Oh.
I found the tunnel entrance in Kvatch.
I need to follow it to the gatehouse so I can raise the gates and let the guards into the castle port yard.
Oh, all my friends are still here though.
Awesome.
Alright, guys.
What is this?
Oh, okay.
It's a little smoky.
Don't fall into the fire.
Please.
Actually, don't fall into the fire.
Don't do that.
Okay.
So far, so good.
That's it?
Wait.
Ah!
Oh!
That's it?
We good?
Okay.
Let's go.
Why?
You get the loot.
If they die!
They're my buddies now.
It's not just about...
Oh.
Oh!
Hello, friends.
I'll let them handle it.
Oh, I got him.
I got him.
Oh, my God.
It's a lizard galore.
Oh!
Oh, uh...
That's the best you can do!
Oh!
Hello.
No, I got him.
Oh!
How many people died?
Oh, no!
Jessen!
Oh, Jessen!
Jessen, no!
Oh!
I told you guys.
It was a death flash.
Oh, buddy.
Oh, my gosh.
So many fallen.
Oh!
Yes!
Thank you, but it's not in vain.
Oh, wait, no, no, no, no, ew.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, it's empty.
Oh, your sacrifice is not in vain.
Yes, yes, thank you, thank you.
Oh,
I'll take that.
Okay.
Let's go talk.
Yes, we did.
Is this not the courtyard, or...
Oh, great hall.
Okay.
Uh...
This part's a bit bugged.
Just enter the castle and get the...
Oh, get the ring?
Okay.
It's bugged.
Go in and get a ring.
Okay.
What the heck is that...
That thing up there?
Oh, at least my friend's in here, though.
Nice.
Spicy lady.
Wait, hold on.
I heard something.
Oh, here it is.
Oh!
Yeah, get his ass.
Uh-oh, I think my friend is about to die.
Oh, nice.
Good job, friend.
I'm going to switch out for steel arrows.
Hot lady up ahead.
Should I, like, try and snipe her, or...
Should we...
Go talk to her.
Oh, there's another one!
Oh, my God.
I don't think she wants to talk.
Nice!
Too hot.
Go have a chat.
All right, let's go have a chat.
Oh, madam!
Your fair hair is so...
Oh, damn, she is...
Oh, my God!
Where did you come from?
He's...
He's scampering.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no!
He's literally a scamp!
It's literally in his name!
He's like, No, m'lady!
Oh, my God.
She's so beautiful.
What's she got?
Fire salts.
Okay.
Nah, take it on.
Aw, my buddy!
We lost him, my buddy.
It's all so heavy, though.
I don't think...
Anybody is alive in here.
I think it's not doing so good.
I think if anybody was still in here...
It's kind of...
Looking rough.
I think it's looking...
Oh.
It's my...
My castle now!
This place has seen better days.
Absolutely.
They didn't even barricade the door.
Oh, my God.
Shoot.
Wait, where's my...
There it is.
Oh, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Ugh.
Please.
Oh, yeah.
Nobody's alive here.
He ate some of my arrows.
Silver.
Anyone else in here?
Most likely.
Okay, so I'm looking for a ring.
Pumpkin.
I'm looking for a ring.
Oh, my gosh.
Dang it, I was supposed to be stealthy!
Oops.
Ugh.
Please.
Die.
Furthest back room.
Okay.
I don't want his skin.
Oh, come on!
Stink.
Fun streamer.
I really want to see the assassination, though.
Hopefully soon.
Oh.
Uh.
I mean, I'm a higher level now, so...
We might be able to.
Really?
Oh.
Sexy lady.
Don't leave.
No.
Why do the sexy ones always leave?
Okay, hold on.
Am I actually probably strong enough, you think?
Sexy lady.
If I...
Serenade you...
Will you...
Look at my hands.
Itina is shaking.
She's so terrified.
Oh!
Like that.
Shaking like a little leaf.
Oh, no.
Not the art.
Okay, nothing over here.
Oh, hail Queen Minto.
Oh my gosh, she's really gone.
A less rude song.
Fundaments of Alchemy.
Galarian the Mystic.
Okay, guys.
I think she's gone.
She's not gone, but you know what I mean.
I don't think she's coming back.
Is what I mean.
Damn it!
No!
Leave!
Ouch.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
One more, one more, one more.
We're too good.
What's in the cupboard?
Ooh, lots of wine.
You think they got that from...
From, uh...
The vineyards?
Alright.
I don't think anybody's alive in here.
Maybe...
An imp.
Yep.
Oh my gosh.
I can't see!
I can't...
I need a break.
I'm-a-tire.
What's in the drawers?
Okay, you're telling me this is a king?
And he has nothing...
Nothing of value in here?
Oranges?
Quills?
What is this?
Ooh.
I found the body of Count Goldwine.
Goldwine!
I should deliver his signet ring to Salvian.
Yeah.
Wait, what was that?
Wait, what just happened?
Oh, yes.
I could take his outfit.
Why is his outfit worth nothing?
They don't want the clothes of a king?
Scampi.
That was...
Oh, I pressed R!
Ow!
I forgot that this was a thing.
Oh my gosh.
I feel like I have to redo the tutorial.
I'll take that, and that, and that.
He keeps his little gold...
Just around.
I could sleep here.
Might be a little...
A little, uh...
I think I would...
Maybe...
The smoke inhalation...
Actually, the smoke inhalation?
How have we not died from that?
Now that I think about it.
There's so much in here.
Hold on.
Let's check the other area.
Oh, wait.
I think this is a dead end.
I think we've searched everything.
Eee, Tina.
She's too powerful.
Hup.
Nice.
I'm sorry.
Where is the count?
Why is he not with you?
Uh...
Lying face down in a pool of blood!
I'm sorry.
Yeah, I'll be dramatic about it.
How dare you mock him?
Oh!
Even in death!
Sorry.
Had you not been instrumental in getting this far, I'd put you down where you stand.
Where is the count's ring?
Do you have it?
Sorry.
Yeah, yeah.
At least, this is safe.
Thank you.
I shall make sure it is protected.
For the time when a new count is crowned.
Here.
Take this.
I have no use for it.
I'm tired of fighting.
It may serve you well and base the count.
Damn, Minto is so insensitive.
Oh!
I took it.
He gave me his clothes.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Thanks!
He should be around the camp somewhere.
He was with the survivors we rescued from the Chapel of Akatosh.
He literally gave me the clothes off his back.
Goodbye.
We did it!
Mirandil.
It's my pleasure.
Please continue.
Yes.
Actually, it's your pleasure.
What's our...
81!
He really likes me.
Take care.
Yeah, you too.
Bye!
We took back the city!
Woohoo!
And, uh...
Can I go this way, or...
Which...
Uh...
Or was it...
Uh, this way?
Oh, yes.
It was this one.
The hero of Kvatch.
That's me.
That's me, all right.
I did it.
Good day.
Yeah, I did it.
Never mind, you don't care.
Good day.
Ha ha ha!
Try on his armor.
Oh, yeah.
We got him.
It smells just like him.
This one?
Oh!
Oh, it's enchanted with...
Mystery!
Ha ha ha!
Good day.
Look at the value.
Wait, I didn't look at the value.
Oh, H for details.
Thank you, guys.
Heetails.
Enchanted...
With...
Uh...
Fortify endurance on self.
Fortify strength on self.
Very cool.
Light armor you'll wear degrades at a normal rate.
Oh.
Aw, man.
All right, let's go talk the more time.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, God.
I'm getting impaled.
Okay, we're fine.
No.
Ha ha ha ha!
Some good armor.
Yeah, we can get rid of the other one.
We can...
We can give it to someone else and they can impersonate, uh...
A, uh...
A soldier.
My athletics.
Let's go, baby.
I think they'll be fine.
There he is.
Are they angry with us?
Hello.
Let me talk to you.
Come with me to Wainan Priory.
Yes!
Where's my horse?
What could we have done to deserve this?
Wait, is he just gonna follow me?
Oh, nice!
Um...
Okay, I have a horse?
Like, somewhere around here.
Uh... Oh!
My horse is so loyal!
Exactly where we left him!
Here, here, here.
Okay, come here.
This is my horse, my steed.
My golden steed.
Now, get on.
Or...
Keep up.
He'll be fine.
Alright, where are we going?
Oh, let's make this quest my...
Uh...
Oh, it is.
Okay.
We are going...
Uh...
Coral?
Oh, yes, a coral.
There it is!
Oh my gosh, you guys, it's so...
It's so far.
Da-da-da-da!
With my ghostly powers!
This is what athletics level 34 gets you.
Uh-oh.
Wait, what's happening here?
Um...
Oh!
You must help!
They're killing everyone at Wayne on Priory!
What?!
Hold on, tell me what happened!
I don't know!
The guy's right behind you!
Prior Maberel is dead!
No kidding, I think they are too!
I think they're...
I think they're right behind!
I was in the sheepfold when they attacked.
I heard the prior talking to someone.
Uh-oh.
Looked around the corner to see who it was.
They looked like travelers.
Ordinary.
Suddenly, weapons appeared in their hands, and they cut the prior down before he could move.
Oh my god!
They saw me watching, and I ran.
Wait!
He's dead?
Where's Joffre?
Yeah.
I don't know.
In the chapel, praying, I think.
You must help us!
Okay!
Oh!
What?
What is he saying?!
Ah!
Mythic Dawn Agent.
God!
I'm helping!
Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap Cap It's blood that came out of nowhere.
Have you seen Grandmaster Joffrey?
No.
Uh, Ero Noir said he was in the chapel.
Quick!
He may need our help.
Where is that guy, anyway?
I thought that was his body for a second.
Where is he?
Did he escape?
Take your gold.
No, I'm looking for Ero Noir.
The guy that was going, Quap, quap.
I can't find him.
He'll come back later.
Okay.
Maybe?
He ran off.
Okay.
That is so funny.
Your timing is excellent.
I'll take the one on the right.
Okay.
Long burn the dragon fire.
The time of cleansing is almost here.
A little closer.
Oops.
Wow, I have a great aim.
Bleed to death.
Paradise awaits.
The dark...
Oh.
My bad.
I was a help, too.
Your back sank, Talos.
I shot the flower vase.
I was praying in the chapel when I heard Priam Abarel shout.
I had just time to arm myself.
The amulet of kings.
I fear that was the target of this attack.
I kept it in a secret room in Wenon House.
We need to go see if it is safe.
Okay.
I'll go check on the amulet.
Oh, me?
We'll go together.
Yes.
But I fear the worst.
Oh, no.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Let me click my...
I didn't...
I barely hit anybody.
Gop, gop, gop, gop, gop.
You good?
Let's go.
Wait.
I fear the enemy came here for the amulet of kings.
Oh.
Look at you with your katana.
Yeah.
He's studying the blade.
He's
studying the blade.
Uh-oh.
I fear we've lost the father.
Wait.
Um...
He came up here and then...
Oh, he's in here!
Oh.
Pull.
They've taken it!
The amulet of kings is gone.
The enemy has defeated us at every turn.
Ah.
I found Martin.
So it has not all gone against us.
Thank Talos for that.
We gained Uriel's heir and lost the amulet of kings.
Martin cannot stay here.
We have driven them off, but they will be back once they learn of Martin's...
He really actually has a katana!
Look at it!
Where will Martin be safe?
Nowhere is truly safe against the power arrayed against us.
But we must play for time at least.
Cloud Ruler Temple, I think.
The hidden fortress of the bridge in the mountains.
Cloud Ruler Temple.
Okay.
A few men can hold it against an army.
We should leave at once.
Okay.
Before we do this...
We should get moving.
I won't rest easy until Martin is safe at Cloud Ruler Temple.
Oh no!
It's empty!
Oh, are we leaving leaving?
Cuz...
He's got a Book of Daedra.
I'm not stealing.
I'm just licking.
Um...
Why is the bone glitching out?
I suggest horse riding to the temple.
It's scenic.
I think we're gonna do it next time.
But also, I wanna go back.
I wanna do...
Okay, if I just leave these guys here...
Can I go back to...
Skingrad and murder those men?
They will follow you.
If I tell them to wait here...
Maybe.
You gotta tell them to wait.
Okay.
Let's continue on to Cloud...
No, no, no.
Wait here.
I was looking forward to reaching Cloud Ruler Temple.
Don't be long.
You just heard about it right now.
My place is at Martin's side.
Okay, you stay here.
Oh, I think he's safe.
We should get moving.
I won't rest easy until Martin is safe with Cloud Ruler Temple.
Yeah, he's not...
He's not moving.
I don't know where the other guy went.
The other priest, but...
I think we're okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
The square goes into the square hole.
And the sheep...
Goes into the sheep hole.
Okay.
Actually, I think I'm gonna do it next time.
Okay, what I'll do is...
I'll get to the temple.
Wherever the heck that is.
There's a temple.
Somewhere.
We'll get there.
Breville.
Come to Breville!
We should make that a sound alert.
Coop, coop, coop, coop.
Oh, north, north.
Oh!
I see it, I see it.
Skyrim?
No way.
Are they connected?
I did.
Please stop.
I think what we'll do is...
We'll take him there.
And then I can go and do the murder.
Next time.
Because I feel like I don't want to just stop in the middle of this quest.
Even though it's like the main quest.
And there's always gonna be something.
But I wanna...
I wanna be able to...
Oh, um...
So...
Sunday.
Sunday, Sunday, Sunday!
Is when we will pick up and we'll murder!
And we will...
Um...
Carry on.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sounds like a plan.
Basically, it gives you a pause once you drop Martin at the temple.
Yeah, I saw some people saying that.
So I think it'll be good to...
To do it.
And then we can, um...
Continue onwards.
Plus, I'm getting a little sleepy.
And I...
Don't know how long the murders will take.
Skyrim is...
Cyrodiil's Canada.
And, uh...
Hail to the hero of Kvatch!
You've done really good so far.
You've picked up this game so fast.
Thank you!
I'm having so much fun, so...
Sunday is psychopath day.
Yeah!
This game is hilarious.
I'm not gonna...
I'm not over...
I can't wait for someone to timestamp it so that I can click back to it.
Maybe I will make it a sound alert.
Gop, gop, gop, gop!
This is...
That's exactly the kind of content I wanted from this game.
So I'm having the most fun.
Wait until you...
Hi!
Oh my gosh!
I want to meet the...
So bad!
I want to meet them.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Gop, gop, gop, gop, gop!
What's up everybody!
Thank you so, so much!
And...
Hopefully...
The game has looked okay while streaming.
With bit rate and...
If I have to...
If I have to turn down some of the plants and stuff, I can do that too.
But...
Just so it looks better on stream.
Oh!
Thank you for the fun.
Thank you!
That was totally fine?
Oh, okay.
Good, good, good.
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I will see you guys when I see you next time!
Yeah!
Bye bye!
Have a good day!
Have a good night!
Bye bye!
Oh!
Oh wait!
You can hear me!
Ah!
You can hear me too!
Oops!
Sorry, if you can hear the BG, I'm also doubling.
Bye bye!
So long!
Hahaha!
Uh...